hey everyone welcome to this full course
video on ethical hacker by simplylearn
in this full course you will learn all
about how to become an ethical hacker
this video will help you get acquainted
with the duties and career prospects of
an ethical hacker
along with various ethical hacking
concepts
here we will learn who is a certified
ethical hacker
the skills and duties of an ethical
hacker
career of an ethical hacker following
which we will give you an insight into
the popular ch version 11 certification
moving ahead we will look into the types
of hackers and then dive deep into
ethical hacking concepts and learn the
process of ethical hacking
we will also go through a hands-on demo
on the various types of cyber attacks
like phishing
sql injection and so on
next we will acquaint you with the
various ethical hacking certifications
available today
and the best books you can learn from
for ethical hacking
finally we will conclude this full
course by providing you with the most
asked ethical hacking interview
questions
our experienced instructor bipin and i
will take you through this full course
and guide you on your journey as an
ethical hacker
you can learn all of these topics in
under 5 hours
so let's begin we will start this full
course with an interesting short video
on ethical hacking
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
you might have heard of several
cyberattack cases where companies have
lost their crucial data
money reputation and customer trust
these attacks are carried out by hackers
who exploit weaknesses in a computer
network
to gain unauthorized access to vital
information
however hacking is not always bad as
there are hackers who work with
different motives
white hat hackers also known as ethical
hackers
hack with permission to defend an
organization
this form of hacking is legal it is
known as
ethical hacking ethical hacking is
distributed into
six different phases the first phase is
reconnaissance
where you collect all the required
information
next is the scanning phase where you try
to spot
any system vulnerability following this
is the gaining access phase where the
spotted vulnerabilities are exploited
in the next stage known as maintaining
access
you try to maintain your access for
future attacks by
installing back doors the fifth phase is
clearing tracks
where you clear all the evidence of the
hack and finally
in the reporting phase you document the
summary of the entire attack
there is and there will always be high
demand for ethical hackers who can
safeguard organizations from
cyber attacks so what are you waiting
for
get certified with simply learn and
become an ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber attacks in the world
now let's begin with who is a certified
ethical hacker a certified ethical
hacker is a person
who's also known as an ethical hacker an
ethical hacker is just the opposite of a
hacker a hacker is a person
who with malicious intent tries to
misuse vulnerabilities that they have
identified in an organization structure
and then gain access to unauthorized
data whereas an ethical hacker
does the same thing they try to locate
the weakness they try to look at the
vulnerabilities
and they see how they can be misused
however the intent is completely
different
and that is what differentiates a hacker
from an ethical hacker
hacker would be a criminal with a
malicious intent
who would try to misuse and personally
gain
by doing criminal activity from that
particular activity that they have done
whereas ethical hacker
would try to help the organization in an
authorized manner
so that's where the permission comes
into the picture the ethical hacker has
permission
from the organization to conduct some
activity that would identify
vulnerabilities or weaknesses
in the information technology structure
of that organization and then once they
have been identified
the ethical hacker would then help the
organization to plug those
vulnerabilities rather than misuse those
vulnerabilities
so any person who completes ch version
10 certification
is known as a certified ethical hacker
so this is a certification once you
complete that once you pass the exams
you can essentially call yourself as a
certified ethical hacker and you're
going to get a certificate with the same
terminology so as you can see in the
diagram your responsibility would be as
a certified ethical hacker would be
with the proper permission of the
organization with the authorization
coming in with contracts coming in
you would legally help the organization
to identify those weaknesses and
vulnerabilities and once you find them
you're going to report them to the
organization
and you're going to help the
organization with remediation plan which
will help them
remediate mitigate and resolve the
vulnerabilities that you have identified
thus making the organization's security
structure a lot better
based on which black hat hackers or
malicious hackers
would be unable to attack the
organization so what is
ch version 10 now this course was
initially introduced in september 2015
and i think if you look at the
versioning this is the 10th version
that is there in the market so
essentially ch or the certified ethical
hacking course as the course itself has
been
for a long time in the industry it's a
very well accepted course
and it's a well-renowned course the
current version as it is
was uh introduced in september 2015 and
is one of the toughest certifications in
the cyber security field
this includes a lot of information that
you have to
learn that you have to know before you
can attempt the certification you will
master
all ethical lacking methodologies that
are used in penetration testing and
ethical hacking situations what does
that mean
that means that ceh version 10 is a
structured course that will help you
look at all the phases that are used in
ethical hacking all the terminologies
that are utilized all the tools that are
utilized in such a manner
that you can penetration test or a
vulnerability assessment
and identify and test the
vulnerabilities for their complexity and
this course
once you complete the course you would
have mastered all the ethical hacking
techniques that are required there are
two exams one is a written exam and the
other is a practical exam now you can
opt for either or
the written exam is basically a multiple
choice question exam
where they'll ask you scenario based
questions and you have to answer those
questions
that is something that we're going to
look into during this video
the practical exam is basically a
simulation exam where they give you a
scenario and you have to complete
some complete those tests and prove that
you are a good ethical hacker
based on the report that you give if the
report tallies to what the test was
you would be clearing that exam so
practical exam is a little bit tougher
it's more hands-on
it tests this actual skills that you
would perform
in a hacking scenario or ethical hacking
scenario does the practical exam
going to be that much tougher the
written exam to give it credence
tests you a lot on your mentality on
your thought process
on your judgment characteristics so they
will give you a scenario
and ask you what do you think is
happening what does this attack
trend amount to or would be then what
what would be the next step in the
particular attack that they're
describing
does it's more of an intellectual test
where your
when your thought process are being
checked and you are giving this exam
so what would be the difference between
these exams in a practical exam
you would be conducting all those steps
yourself and you would be
reaching a conclusion so here
essentially you're being tested
on the skills that you have developed on
the execution part of it
and to see whether you can execute a
test end to end whereas
in a written exam you would be put in
the middle of a test
where you have to assume something where
you have to understand what the steps
would have been
performed in the in the previous steps
and what would be the expected result
and you're supposed to analyze that and
then come to the
correct answer so if there is a question
which which exam is better written or
practical
the answer to that is from an
intellectual perspective a written exam
would be a lot tougher than a practical
exam
and from an execution perspective a
practical exam would be tougher than a
written exam
so it depends on us which exam we want
to give both of them are widely accepted
and well respected
in the information security field so
it's just the option
that we choose which exam we want to
give now this
course the version 10 course is purely a
tag-based course
okay it is an offensive course there is
no defensive mechanisms
so if you're looking for questions of
how to secure yourself on the internet
how to securely configure operating
system or how to securely configure a
server
how to configure a firewall this is not
the certification
this basically talks about attacking
those devices so if you come across a
firewall how would you test a firewall
how would you identify vulnerabilities
in those and how would you bypass a
firewall
similarly if you come across a server
how are you going to attack and hack the
server
let it be windows or linux based so this
basically becomes a attack attack-based
course you're
looking at offensive mechanisms over
here and not defensive ones at all
so what's new in this version in this
version there's a new module
for iot internet of things it focuses on
emerging attacks vectors like cloud
artificial intelligence and
machine learning it basically talks
about smart devices and it talks about
the vulnerabilities the risk that the
smart devices face in today's world
uh for example it will tell you about
the industries that are utilizing all
these smart devices
why are they utilizing it for what kind
of devices they are utilizing
and what are the risks within those
devices it will also give you a lot of
tools
for you to practice upon to identify
such iot devices
what would constitute an iot or internet
of things device any device which has an
ip address and can connect to the
internet and create data so even your
smart watch
your smartphone your cars that have
internet connectivity nowadays
uh your google homes amazon alexas
all of these devices would come under
the iot umbrella
and have you ever wondered about sitting
at home having a wi-fi
having all of these devices even a smart
tv if you will connected to the wi-fi
and have you ever questioned how a
hacker would then be able to access your
home through all of these devices
record information and basically just
spy on you
similarly an organization where they're
utilizing iot
they would be vulnerable for the same
vulnerabilities and
this course does include iot security to
a certain extent
uh where we talked about vulnerabilities
and how to identify those
vulnerabilities in iot
then there's a new vulnerability
analysis module where it gives you risk
assessment it talks about cvss scoring
systems
it talks about how to do a vulnerability
management program in the first place
what are the steps required in a
vulnerability management program how
should it be reputable and how it should
be measurable as a program
and what should be the outcome so
basically it will give you a structured
way of how to
do a vulnerability management assessment
and
how do you want to achieve the end goal
thus leading you to a penetration test
so all the modules are leveled up what
do you mean by leveled up that means
they've been updated to the latest
tools latest standards latest
technologies so you've got cryptographic
attacks you have
got attacks on applications like sql
injection we'll be talking about packet
sniffing using
various tools all of these are upgraded
which means they're up to the latest
operating system so even
when we do this course you'll be looking
at operating systems like windows 10
windows 8
windows server 2012 windows server 2016
kali linux machines
android machines and ubuntu desktop as
well
so all of the operating systems are
latest the tools are latest
and you will be interacting with these
tools and then there is a mobile
security toolkit as well
which will help you do a penetration
test on a mobile device
so these are what is new in version 10.
now let's talk about the roles and
responsibilities that ethical hacker
should have when they actually go into
the world
now what are the responsibilities rules
what are the capabilities that we should
have
that we should be able to look at
scripts that would test for
vulnerability so for example a sql
injection attack
it's a script-based attack let's say a
cross-site scripting attack that is
again going to be a script-based attack
so we uh maybe we want to go ahead a
little bit
look at windows systems and do a
powershell attack and know
about partial scripting a little bit if
you look at linux windows there's a bash
shell where there's bash scripting and
you'll want to learn that scripting as
well
now the course doesn't include all these
scripting languages
it does help you understand what these
scripting languages are and it does have
some basic introduction to how these
languages can be utilized to create
those scripts
then we also want to develop tools to
increase security you want to look at
those commands that are utilized on all
operating systems you want to look at
the capabilities of the operating
systems
of how to create security parameters and
ensure the operating systems and
applications devices are secure
uh you should be able to perform risk
assessment now when you say risk
assessment
risk assessment is the likelihood of an
attack being actually executed on an
organization
based on the threats and the
vulnerabilities that we have identified
so risk assessment is something that
you find out a vulnerability and then
you try to figure out in a hypothetical
manner
of what is the likelihood of that
vulnerability being exploited by a
hacker
if they find that vulnerability and if
they do execute that
what is the impact that is going to
happen on the organization
and what is the penalties or the
repetitions
that the organization is going to face
if that vulnerability is exploited
that's what a risk assessment is then we
should also be able to
develop security policies or set up
security policies and implement them
to ensure that the security mechanisms
are standardized
and are consistent and then we should
also
look at training staff for network
security to ensure that they are aware
of these vulnerabilities and they know
what their responsibilities are
to maintain some semblance of security
in the organization
so why do we want to become a certified
ethical hacker now
since you're watching this video it's
easy to assume that we all are
interested in security we all are
interested in hacking but hacking is not
a real job
for us to get a job in the industry on a
security parameter or information
security parameter we want to become a
certified ethical hacker
so if you look at the popular hacking
cases that have happened in 1990s there
was a national crackdown on criminals
microsoft nt
operating system was hacked now this was
back in the 90s when security wasn't
that much evolved and there were a lot
of attacks back then
that crippled infrastructure that
crippled banks when they started
realizing that computing isn't as easy
as it seems
of course if you use a computer the
functionality is always there but if the
functionality is not properly configured
you're just exposing yourself to cyber
criminals where they're going to steal
information
and your organization may just go
bankrupt because of that
in 2013 an example adobe reported 2.9
million accounts as stolen
in 2016 kaspersky which is a internet
security firm
uh announced that there was 758 million
malicious attacks that occurred
worldwide imagine that 758
million malicious attacks that were
identified and reported
in 2018 facebook reported a loss of 30
millions to
accounts that were stolen 2018 again
quora
reported 100 million customer accounts
being stolen and
in 2018 again marriott 500 million
travelers accounts stolen and
manipulated now when you see account
first stolen how does it affect the
organizations now first and foremost
if those accounts were stolen that means
usernames and passwords were cracked and
those accounts may have contained credit
card information
or may have contained some personal
information that would identify the
person
the person and does make them gullible
for a social engineering attack or an
identity theft attack
so it has a cascading effect if i would
have been affected
or you would have been affected with
these attacks the repercussions would
have been catastrophic your credit card
information being stolen that means
somebody else would have misused it
and you would have uh seen a huge bill
come to you come your way
now you can go back to the bank and
dispute that but that that's again
uh a dispute that you're trying to uh
have with the bank for something that
you didn't do which requires a lot of
energy and
a lot of time and at the end of it
somebody has to pay for that particular
loss now in this scenario the bank would
have had to bear the loss but then
that's a loss for the bank and bank
doesn't want to do that
and that's where they would try to hire
certified ethical hackers
who would try to test these
vulnerabilities and plug them in
so that the end consumer is also secured
the bank is also secure
right in this case uh marriott there
were 500 million travelers accounts that
were stolen a lot of credit card
information
uh was uh leaked out email email
accounts were
hacked and compromised and thus there
was a lot of
replication that happened now the thing
is that there are also
laws that these organizations need to
adhere to that
tell the organizations how to keep their
information secure
and also have penalties in place if the
organization gets hacked
and the penalties are pretty severe so
organizations do not want to get hacked
or do not want to get compromised
not only from the customers perspective
where they would be losing customers
losing reputations and then thus facing
losses
but also from a legislative perspective
where they would have to pay fines to
the government
for the frauds that have happened so
these are some of the popular hacking
cases that have cost these organizations
quite a lot of money
and does uh they have a lot of security
in mind
uh if you look at the news uh in bbc
news there was something reported from a
french police that there was a virus
that infected more under 850 000
computers worldwide now on the similar
lines if you
remember ransomwares and if you look at
wannacry that happened in 2018 or 2017
it also cost the world four billion
dollars in losses
during that just one small month of its
infection
then apple google basically disclosed
that a large-scale hacking effort
was targeted at apple devices and this
has been uh it has reported that there
was a sustained effort to hack
high iphones over a period of at least
two years
which means that there's a specific
target towards apple consumers
and they are at a higher risk of getting
hacked than others
then the texas government organizations
hit by ransomware attack
so hackers have infected 23
organizations connected to local
government
in the u.s state of texas with
ransomware that means that their
databases have been
encrypted the government themselves do
not have access to that database the
databases could have been compromised by
the hackers
and that means that whatever services
were being provided to the users based
on that database
may no longer be available to the end
users because of the ransomware
now moving on with these why won't do we
want to become a certified ethical
hacker
increased attacks lead to more job
openings now if you look at ransomware
the monaco attack that happened in 2017
there was a knee-jerk reaction given by
the
rest of the world for i.t security
suddenly budgets or started opening up
suddenly people wanted more ethical
hackers on their payrolls to test for
vulnerabilities
in uk and europe we have gdpr which is
again another law
that imposes cv of penalties on
organizations that get
hacked and for not having proper
security and a voluntary assessment and
penetration
testing program in place so that leads
to a lot of job requirements as well
where
organizations look at people with the
special skill set
to help them mitigate the
vulnerabilities to keep to safeguard
them
and their customers from hackers and
also from penalties
from law enforcement and governments so
does the demand keeps on increasing for
ethical hackers which automatically
means that the salaries are going to
increase as well
so more the demand lesser the supply
higher the salaries
that's plain economics then challenge
hacker with malaysia's intent
so from an ethical hacker's perspective
it is our duty to safeguard an
organization which means that will be
pitched against
hackers and we have to ensure that those
hackers would be challenged to the
maximum limit before they even try to
get access
to any of the resources that we are
trying to protect it offers
a boost in your career so more uh
efforts that you put in more
vulnerabilities that you find the better
the career prospects that you have
and the better job aspects that you're
going to get and this also
lets you keep yourself updated on the
latest technology as the technology
progresses
as we evolve on technology security will
also evolve
and the ethical hacker would need to
keep themselves updated on these
technologies
so this is what is a plus point to
become a certified ethical hacker
with the increase in the number of cyber
crimes across the globe
there is also an increase in the number
of cyber security jobs and the role of
an ethical hacker tops the list
hi guys this is shruti from simply learn
and today i will run you through this
video on ethical hacking career
so let's get started and explore the
world of ethical hacking
let's begin with a few facts did you
know that by the year 2021 there will be
3.5 million
cyber security job openings that is a
huge number isn't
it and also according to the u.s bureau
of labor statistics
there will be 28 increase in the number
of jobs from
2016 to 2026 for information security
analysts which includes
ethical hackers this proves that there
is a great demand
for ethical hackers at the moment as i
mentioned earlier
the number of cyber crimes across the
world will increase as the digital era
will only continue to grow
organizations will be on the lookout to
hire professionals who can fight these
cyber crimes
and protect the company's data and to
fight these cyber crimes we will require
individuals who can think like a hacker
and who is that well to do this job we
have ethical hackers
as you might be knowing an ethical
hacker is trained to discover system
vulnerabilities
an ethical hacker is also known as a
white hat hacker
he or she is given authorization from
the company to perform security
assessments
and at the end an ethical hacker would
have to report the findings
back to the company so that the
vulnerabilities can be fixed
an ethical hacker performs these
security assessments with the help of
various hacking techniques and tools
let's now move on to our next topic that
is the steps to become an ethical hacker
you might wonder how to start your
ethical hacking career right
well i will take you through that step
by step firstly the candidate must have
a computer science
or an information technology bachelor's
degree it is also possible to become an
ethical hacker without these degrees but
provided you have the required skill
sets and experience
the next requirement to be an ethical
hacker is that the candidate must have a
minimum of two years of experience in
the
information security field you have to
start your career with a software or a
networking job and only then can you
move on to the
ethical hacking field you have to start
your career with
a software or a networking job and only
then can you move into the ethical
hacking field
coming to the certifications it is
necessary for the candidate to hold
various cyber security certifications
certifications play a vital role in the
field of cyber security
your job opportunities can solely depend
on these certifications
to become an ethical hacker you can
start off with the foundational level
certifications
such as the ccna and comptria security
plus certifications
finally the last step to become an
ethical hacker is to clear the certified
ethical hacker examination ch
certification is provided by the ec
council
it trains the candidate to protect a
company's network by using the same
tools and methods that a hacker would
use
the ch exam will have a duration of 4
hours
with 125 number of questions if the
candidate clears this
exam then he or she will become a
certified ethical hacker
now that you know the steps to become an
ethical hacker let's look into the skill
sets which are required to help you
achieve these steps
first and foremost an ethical hacker
needs to have an in-depth knowledge of
the working of the operating systems
knowledge of windows linux and macintosh
operating systems
is required for penetration testing
creating exploits and
bug hunting programming will be
important so knowledge of programming
languages such as cec plus plus html
python and php will be very helpful
basic knowledge of networking tcp
protocols and osi model
is necessary as networking is the
foundation of cyber security for
securing databases
knowledge of sql nosql postgresql
is necessary cryptography is used to
secure
information it is the process of
converting data from a readable format
to
a non-readable format and vice versa
cryptanalysis
is decryption without a secret key in
most cases
certified ethical hacker would need to
perform cryptanalysis
hence ethical hacker has to be
comfortable with cryptography
and cryptanalysis ethical hackers should
be proficient
in network security control measures
such as
intrusion detection and intrusion
prevention techniques
now let's move on to the
responsibilities which are taken
care of by an ethical hacker let's have
a look at these responsibilities
an ethical hacker is responsible for
scanning systems
open and closed ports using tools like
nessus and nmap vulnerabilities and
threats are identified by doing this
in addition to scanning for
vulnerabilities they also search the
deep corners of the network to spot
critical information such as
passwords which can make the
organization vulnerable to an attack
in addition to building and maintaining
ids ips and firewalls
they also try to evade these security
measures to gauge the performance of the
systems
a lot of times a company's online fraud
or online theft incidents are looked
into by an ethical hacker
an ethical hacker also checks for
sniffing networks and hijacked web
servers and applications
those were the responsibilities of an
ethical hacker now let's look into the
various job roles an ethical hacker can
apply for
it is a misconception that an ethical
hacker will they also try to be
penetration
well there are a number of other jobs an
ethical hacker can apply for the
different job roles such as that of a
penetration tester
information security analyst security
consultant
and an information security manager
let's have a look at each of these job
roles
one by one a penetration tester performs
the typical responsibility of an ethical
hacker
that is he or she tries to exploit a
security system's vulnerabilities
this is carried out using different
hacking tools and techniques
an ethical hacker can also apply for the
role of an information security analyst
there is a difference between the job
roles of a penetration tester and that
of an information security analyst
here the candidate will be required to
primarily design and protect the
organization's network from various
cyber attacks
finally the candidate is also required
to document the identified security
breaches
so that it can be omitted the next time
the responsibilities of a security
consultant is more or less similar to
that of an information security analyst
that we saw previously
as a security consultant you will be
responsible to design
implement and maintain barrier security
architectures
in addition to this you're also required
to upgrade the security systems as and
when required
finally an ethical hacker can also apply
to the role of an information security
manager
as the name suggests this role will
require the candidate to possess
managerial skills as an information
security manager
is responsible to help the it and the
information security team
now that we have seen the
responsibilities the skills and the
steps to become an ethical hacker
let's have a look at the different
companies hiring ethical hackers
to name a few we have bank of america
ernest and young kpmg
urban pro and ibm let's now look into
the salary structure of an ethical
hacker
well in india the average annual salary
of a certified ethical hacker is nearly
4 lakhs 76 000 rupees and in the us the
average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker
is 91 000 now i will guide you through a
sample resume of a penetration
tester as you can see on your screens
this is a sample resume of a penetration
tester we will look into this resume
closely and understand
how your resume should look like if you
are applying for the role of a
penetration tester
as always you can start off with your
name and your email id
and your phone number followed by a
brief summary of
your current job profile it is prefer to
add your linkedin profile link here
and also your github profile link if you
have one
as i mentioned earlier this is a sample
resume for a penetration tester
and hence we have to have more than two
years of experience in the information
security field
as you can see under the experience
section the candidate has
two prior experiences out of which the
first experience is that of a software
tester and second is that of a
penetration tester you would have to
mention your latest or current
experience at the beginning you can
mention your job role
and the company and the duration under
which you can list out the various
responsibilities that you are looking
into currently
if you are a penetration tester you can
mention responsibilities such as
security monitoring
black box testing documentation of the
results
vulnerability scanning and so on below
this
you can mention your first company's
experience
with the roles and responsibilities that
you have performed earlier
here the candidate was a software tester
before becoming a penetration tester
let's move on to the education section
here the candidate holds a bachelor's
degree in computer science
you can mention your degree followed by
the university name
or if you're applying for any other role
in the cyber security domain
it is recommended that you list out the
certifications as well
to start off with a ccna certification
will be preferred
followed by a certified ethical hacker
certification which is a must if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester
in addition to it the certified expert
penetration tester certification
will also hold a great advantage after
mentioning the certifications
you can go ahead and mention your skill
sets here we have the technical skills
and non-technical skills
under technical skills you can mention
the programming languages that you know
here we have c c plus plus java perl you
can also mention the operating systems
that you have worked on for example
windows linux unix
and in addition to the programming
languages and the os you can also
mention
the tools that you know such as nmap
metasploit tools which will be helpful
if you are
applying for the role of a penetration
tester then you can also mention
encryption technologies
knowledge of sql and bug tracking
systems if you have worked on them
before
if you have participated in a
code-a-thon you can mention that here as
well
under the non-technical skills you can
mention various
competitions that you have taken part in
and the games that you like
and other extracurricular activities
finally you can also mention the
projects undertaken
under the projects undertaken you can
talk about the various projects that you
have performed in your company
or outside the company here we have two
projects one as a software test engineer
and second one as a penetration tester
so this is how a resume of a penetration
tester will look like
let us understand the importance of the
ca certification before getting to know
about its content
so why should you take up the ch version
11. the certified ethical hacker is the
most trusted ethical hacking
certification
and a recommended one by employers
around the globe
since the introduction of the ca
certification in 2003
it is globally recognized as a standard
within the information security field
the ch version 11 by ec council
continues to keep up to the standard
and it familiarizes the latest hacking
techniques and teaches you advanced
hacking tools and exploits used
the ch version 11 aligns with the
current cyber security market
requirements
and adds the latest advancements in the
cybersecurity field
the ca certification helps and trains
you to think like a hacker
and this in turn helps you beat a hacker
and defend your network
after obtaining the ca certification
you'll be a certified ethical hacker
a certified ethical hacker is a skilled
professional working in a red team
environment
who safeguards networks and understands
attack strategies and mimics the skills
of malicious hackers
certified ethical hackers discover
vulnerabilities in a system and operate
with permission from the system owners
only
so who can become a certified ethical
hacker and who can take up the ca
certification
let us have a look at that now
in the first case to be eligible for the
ca certification exam you need to attend
the official training from
authorized ec council training partners
it can be an online training or
tutor-led training from ec council
learning partners
only then are you eligible to take up
the ca certification exam
so a candidate who has completed an
official ec council training is eligible
to take up the exam without going
through the application process
or in the second case in order to be
considered for this credential
you need to have at least two years of
work experience in the information
security domain
and you must pay a non-refundable
application fee
and submit an eligibility application
form
once it is approved you can take up the
ch exam
after the application is approved you
can purchase the test voucher
in the latest version of the ceh we will
see the addition of various core
concepts
moving on to our next topic let us see
how different the ch version 11
is and few of its objectives
firstly it outlines ethical hacking
concepts cyber kill chain concepts and
overview of information security and
various laws and regulations related to
information security
this certification briefs you about the
faces of system hacking
attacking techniques and how you can
maintain access
it also briefs you about footprinting
concepts and ways of utilizing food
printing tools along with necessary
countermeasures
the next objective is to familiarize
with vulnerability assessment
along with the hands-on experience of
various scanning tools
next we have cyber security threats like
malware threats analysis
of various worms viruses and trojans
various malware concepts packets
sniffing concepts and techniques have
been introduced into this domain
it also highlights the concepts related
to social engineering
denial of service attacks sql injection
and aviation techniques
it also speaks about wireless hacking
concepts and mobile device management
the concept of operational technology is
a new addition this time
next is getting acquainted with security
solutions like firewalls honeypots ips
their evasion and protection our fifth
point is knowing various topics in
cryptography
like encryption algorithms public key
infrastructure and cryptanalysis
moving on the next objective is to
incorporate padded security os
as it offers better performance on lower
powered laptops and machines when
compared to kali linux
next is to learn to recognize and deal
with iot based vulnerabilities and
attacks with the ch version 11 course
that covers the latest iot hacking tools
you would be required to ensure the
safety of iot devices
our next point is with respect to the
evolving cloud industry
you would need to learn how to identify
and defend cloud-based threats and
attacks
the latest version of ch includes new
operating systems and windows 10
configured with domain controller
and vulnerable web applications for
improving hacking skills
finally what is different is that more
than 50 percent of the ch version 11
course is dedicated to practical skills
in live ranges by our ec council labs ec
council leads in this aspect of the
industry
now that we saw the ch exam objectives
let us look into the ch
exam topics weightage
as you see on your screens this is a pie
chart with nine domains in ch
along with their weightages you can
prepare for your exam accordingly
let us move on and take a closer look at
each of these domains their respective
subdomains and their descriptions
our first domain is information security
and ethical hacking
overview this domain consists of
questions from information security
cyber kill chain concepts ethical
hacking concepts various hacking
concepts
and information security laws and
standards
you can expect a total number of eight
questions from this domain
the weightage of this section is six
percent
the second domain is reconnaissance
techniques under the subdomains we have
footprinting and reconnaissance
at first this covers various topics like
footprinting concepts footprinting
methodology
email footprinting footprinting through
web services
dns footprinting footprinting through
social engineering etc
the next subdomain in this section is
scanning networks
scanning networks covers various
concepts like scanning tools
host discovery port and service
discovery os discovery
draw network diagrams scanning beyond
ids
firewall etc and our third subdomain
under reconnaissance techniques
is enumeration various topics like
snmp enumeration ntp and nfs enumeration
smtp and dns enumeration
and enumeration counter measures are
covered under this subdomain
a total of 26 questions will be asked
from this domain
under footprinting and reconnaissance
you will have 10 questions
and under scanning networks and other 10
and finally under enumeration you'll
have six questions
a total weightage of 21 is given to this
particular topic
our third domain is system hacking faces
and attack techniques
under our third domain our first sub
domain is about vulnerability analysis
this subdomain covers topics on
vulnerability assessment
vulnerability classification
vulnerability assessment solutions and
tools
and various vulnerability assessment
reports our next sub domain is about
system hacking
you have concepts like gaining access
cracking passwords vulnerability
exploitation
escalating privileges maintaining access
covered under this subdomain
and finally we have malware threads
under this domain
malware threads incorporate concepts
like apt concepts trojan concepts
virus and worm concepts malware analysis
and so on
a total of 21 questions will be asked
from this domain
under vulnerability analysis there will
be nine questions asked
system hacking and other six questions
and finally under malware threats you
will have six other questions asked
that sums up to a total 21 with a
weightage of 17
for this domain our fourth domain is
about
network and perimeter hacking
here you have various sub domains and
one of it is social engineering
under social engineering you will be
asked questions based on social
engineering techniques
insider threats impersonation on social
networking sites identity theft and so
on
you'll also have various question on the
sniffing concepts as it is another sub
domain
you can also expect questions from the
denial of service subdomain
here questions related to botnets and
ddos attacks will be asked
various session hijacking concepts are
another crucial part of this domain
the final subdomain is about evading ids
firewalls and honeypots
here various concepts on ids ips
firewall and honeypots are covered
you will need to understand how to evade
ideas and firewalls
and how to detect honey pots a total
number of 18 questions will be asked
from the fourth domain that was network
and perimeter hacking
and the weightage for this domain is 14
our fifth domain is about web
application hacking and our first
subdomain in it
is hacking web servers this incorporates
concepts related to web server attacks
web server attack tools patch management
and so on
the next sub domain is about hacking web
applications
here you have various concepts related
to bypass client-side controls analyze
web applications
footprint web infrastructure attack
access controls
and how to perform injection attacks and
so on
finally under the sql injection
subdomain you will have questions based
on sql injection the types of sql
injection
the sql injection methodology sql
injection tools
aviation techniques and sql injection
counter measures
here a total of 20 questions will be
asked from this domain
and that is a weightage of 16 will be
given to the web application hacking
domain
our six domain is solely devoted to
wireless network hacking
this domain focuses on hacking wireless
networks
various wireless concepts wireless
encryption wireless threats
wireless hacking tools various hacking
methodologies bluetooth hacking
and wireless counter measures are
covered a total of eight questions will
be asked from this domain with a
weightage of six percent
our seventh domain is all about mobile
platform iot
and ot hacking our first sub domain here
is hacking mobile platforms
here the concepts that are touched upon
are mobile platform attack vectors
hacking android os hacking ios mobile
device management and mobile security
guidelines and tools
our next sub domain here is about iot
and ot hacking which covers concepts on
iot hacking tools its methodologies
counter measures
and it also speaks about ot concepts ot
attacks
ot hacking tools and ot counter measures
you have a total of 10 questions asked
from this domain with a weightage of 8
percent
the next domain is very interesting and
it is all related to cloud
the cloud computing domain covers
concepts based on cloud computing
server-less computing cloud computing
threats cloud hacking and cloud security
the weightage given to this domain is
six percent with the total number of
questions of seven
and finally we have cryptography as our
ninth domain
as the name suggests this domain covers
topics based on cryptography concepts
encryption algorithms
cryptography tools public key
infrastructure email
encryption disk encryption crypt
analysis and counter measures
and seven questions will be asked from
this domain with a weightage of six
percent
now that you saw the ch exam topic's
weightage
let us have a closer look at the ch exam
details
let us first have a look at the ch exam
based on mcqs
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker with the exam code of 312-50
this exam will have 125 questions with a
time limit of
4 hours the test format is multiple
choice questions
the pass percentage varies ideally
between 60 to 85 percent
now let's have a look at the ch
practical exam details
in order to gain the ch master
recognition it is mandatory that you
take up the ch practical exam as well
the exam title is certified ethical
hacker practical
and this practical exam will have 20
questions with a duration of six
hours the exam format will be ilab cyber
range
and finally the passing score for the ch
practical exam is at 70 percent
after clearing both the mcq based exam
and the practical exam
you can get the ch master recognition
now that we had a look at the ch exam
details let us have a look at the career
prospects
for a professional with this
certification having the ch
certification
guarantees that you have an insight into
the hacking world
hence companies want to hire
professionals who can think like a
hacker and safeguard their networks and
systems
a candidate with the ca certification
can apply for various cyber security job
roles such as penetration tester
security engineer and information
security analyst from the long list
according to pay scale the annual
average salary of a ch professional in
india is rupees 5
lakhs per annum meanwhile in the united
states a professional holding the ca
certification earns nearly 93 000
on an average basis annually now that
you had a look at the ch version 11
certification
and its career prospects what are you
waiting for get certified with simply
learn and back that ca certification
when we hear the term hacker we may
picture a dangerous cyber criminal
however not all hackers are inherently
bad
they are powerful individuals who use
their technical skills to break into
computer networks and bypass security
measures
hacking is not always bad and it is to
be noted that the world
of computers is actually safer to an
extent because of a particular type of
hacker
a hacker is deemed to be good or bad
depending on their motive and whether or
not they are breaking the law
in this video we will acquaint you with
the differences between a white hat
hacker black hat hacker and a grey
attacker
through a short story hackers are
basically categorized by the type of
metaphorical hat they don't
white hat grey hat and black hat hackers
can either be
a black hat or a white hat or a grey hat
hackers can be good or bad depending on
which color hat they decide to wear
and by this we mean their hacking motifs
and obviously not in the sense of
creating a fashion statement here
let's have a look at our story our story
here revolves around dan who is the
owner of a company that provides a
platform for video conferencing
his platform enables online
communication for video meetings
audio meetings and webinars just like
other video conferencing platforms his
platform too has built-in features like
chat
recording screen sharing and so on
everything went well and his business
increased tremendously with the onset of
the covet 19 pandemic
covert 19 accelerated the rise of the
worldwide digital economy and it made
people rapidly adopt video conferencing
tools and apps
in a contactless world starting from
employee interactions to family
get-togethers to virtual workout classes
everything happened virtually dance
video conferencing platform enabled
long distance communication and enhanced
collaboration
so now you might be wondering what could
have gone wrong well there are many
risks involved when it comes to the
safety of these online platforms
online meeting rooms are susceptible to
a number of digital threats dan received
complaints from his customers
that his platform was insecure and safe
anymore
little did dan know that the popularity
of his video conferencing platform made
hackers eager to disrupt the virtual
meetings and hijacked the conferences
his platform witnessed complaints like
the addition of an unknown participant
in every meeting room
someone covering up information that is
being presented and also unknown screen
recording of a meeting to name a few
these intruders were sneaky hackers who
tried to gain access to sensitive
information and who tried to disrupt
meetings and how did these hackers
manage to do all this
well this was done by exploiting
weaknesses in dance computer network
in order to obtain unauthorized access
to crucial data and sensitive
information
this is known as hacking and the
individuals who carry this out are known
as hackers
in this form of hacking that dan
witnessed hackers exploited dan's
company's security posture by
identifying weaknesses in it
in order to intrude into the meetings
and gain access to business data or
personal data
and this form of hacking is definitely
bad and unethical
the hackers who carried this against
dance company are known as
black hat hackers these hackers are
cyber criminals who carry out cyber
attacks with a negative intention
these attacks can be in the form of
trojan virus malware attacks
phishing attacks ddos attacks man in the
middle attacks
sequel injection attacks and so on so
who
exactly is a black hat hacker like in
the case of dance organizations
cyber attack black hat hackers are
highly skilled cyber criminals who break
into computer systems
and networks with malicious intent they
illegally hack into a system and this is
obviously without the system owners
approval
such hackers do not abide by the loss
they violate laws and disrupt networks
the motive behind these attacks vary
from monetary gains to personal profit
usually they are for monetary gains
black hat hackers may violate the
confidentiality integrity or
availability of a company's systems and
data
they may also use malware to destroy
files or steal
passwords credit card numbers and other
confidential information
black hat hackers are also sometimes
called crackers
so this is who a black hat hacker is
moving back to dan's story
black hat hackers disrupted his business
and he lost his customers as nobody
wished to communicate on an unsecure
platform
it is but true right would you be okay
to use a platform that is unsafe
none of us want to have unknown people
in our meetings right
this is how dan's customers felt too and
this news spread and his company's
reputation took a bad hit
that is when ted approached dan so who
is dead
let's have a look at that now ted who
was unknown to dan explained to him that
he found dan's network to be weak
ted told dan that he has identified
vulnerabilities in dance systems
and networks and he will fix them
provided dan pays him well
dan had nothing to lose and without any
further delay he paid ted
a good amount of money to fix the
vulnerabilities in dance networks
on receiving the money ted began his
work and he fixed all the issues and
vulnerabilities in dan's network
he made sure that nobody can exploit
dan's network vulnerabilities again
and this way he safeguarded dance
network for the time being
so who is dead well he's called a grey
hat hacker
as they say not all things are black and
white so is the concept of grey hat
hackers
as fascinating as the name sounds let us
dive deep into understanding
the role of a grey hat hacker a grey hat
is a security expert who may at times
violate the laws or the ethical
standards
however they do not carry a malicious
intent unlike a black hat hacker
hence they are known to work both
defensively and offensively
they land between the good and the bad
gray hat hackers look for
vulnerabilities in a system without
permission but with good intentions
just like how ted informed dan about how
he could exploit dan's system
vulnerabilities
grey hat hackers inform an organization
the same
and in return ask for a fee to fix it
in some cases when the organization
doesn't comply grey hat hackers may
become black hat hackers
although a grey hat hacker's intention
might not be bad
what they do is still illegal since they
do not have permission to break into
another system
back to our story although dance issue
was sorted by ted for the time being he
had a few concerns
his first concern was history repeating
itself yes he was worried about what if
black hat hackers hack into his systems
again
although his system vulnerabilities are
fixed at the moment it was a matter of
time before they could be exploited
again with new hacking techniques
his next thought was to have a
professional who could constantly keep a
tab on his networks and protect it from
hackers
don't you think his concerns were
justified yes it was as this was the
only way he could provide a safe and
secure video conferencing platform in
the long run
that is when dan's friend came to his
rescue and introduced anne the ethical
hacker to him
and being an ethical hacker assured dan
that she would scan and identify his
network for system vulnerabilities
before an outsider exploits it
and she would fix those vulnerabilities
on a regular basis
[Music]
such ethical hackers like anne are
called white hat hackers
now that we saw who black hat hackers
and grey hat hackers were
it is time we learn about our third type
of hacker who is a white attacker
a white hat hacker gains access to
networks with an intention to fix the
identified weaknesses
they also perform penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments and break
into systems with permission
they search for loopholes or
vulnerabilities in any given piece of
technology just like how a black hat
hacker would do
however white hat hackers harden their
organization system before the bad guy
can get in
their goal is to spot system and network
vulnerabilities in order to improve
system security
white hat hackers are also known as
ethical hackers since they obey the law
of the land and follow a code of
headaches
many companies and government
organizations employ white hat hackers
to help them secure their systems
these hackers are typically hired by
organizations to look for
vulnerabilities in a system like
other hackers the only difference being
they are given permission to break in
once dan spots the vulnerabilities she
documents her findings and gives dan
advice on how
to fix them or she'll even take it up to
fix them so that an outsider cannot spot
it in the future
and does this on a regular basis as
system updates happen regularly and it
is imperative to be on track with it and
fix new vulnerabilities
this made sure dan's network is now safe
and secure
gradually he regained his customers
trust and his platform got back to being
one of the best
and safest platforms for video
conferencing
this resulted in a huge business growth
and dan was very happy
just like how ann put an end to dance
business problems
there are many white hat hackers out
there who are in great demand by
organizations to safeguard their
networks from cyber attacks
and if you are interested in a career in
ethical hacking then simply learn can
help you fulfill your dreams
simply learn ch version 11 certification
provides you the hands-on training
required to master the techniques
hackers use to penetrate network systems
and fortify your system against it
this ethical hacking course is aligned
with the latest ch version 11 by ec
council
and will adequately prepare you to
increase your blue team skills
so what are you waiting for get
certified with simply learn and become a
certified ethical hacker and put an end
to the cyber crimes in the world
remember the more active white hat
hackers are the fewer opportunities
black hat hackers
have for system exploitation we humans
are highly tech savvy in today's times
with the extensive use of the internet
and modern technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our digital data
such as net banking information account
credentials
and medical reports to name a few have
you heard about the deadly wannacry
ransomware attack
the attack happened in may 2017 in asia
and then it spread across the world
within a day
more than 230 000 computers were
infected
across 150 countries the wannacry
cryptowork
encrypted the data and locked the users
out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of 300 to 600
in bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of microsoft windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of april 2017
were targeted in this attack the
wannacry attack took a toll on every
sector
top tier organizations like hitachi
nissan
and fedex had to put their businesses on
hold
as their systems were affected too now
this is what you call a cyber attack to
prevent such attacks
cyber security is implemented we can
define cyber security as the practice of
protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components
from unauthorized digital attacks these
illegal attacks are often referred to as
hacking
packing refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network
to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems
this is a misconception that hacking is
always wrong
there are hackers who work with
different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers
are individuals who illegally hack
on the contrary we have white hat
hackers who exploit the vulnerabilities
in the system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization
this form of hacking is absolutely legal
and ethics hence
they are also often referred to as
ethical hackers
in addition to these hackers we also
have the grey hat hackers
as the name suggests the colored gray is
a blend of both white and black
these hackers discover vulnerabilities
in the system and report it
to the system's ownership which is a
good app
but they do this without seeking the
owner's approval
sometimes grey hat hackers also ask for
money in return for the spotted
vulnerabilities
now that you have seen the different
types of hackers let's understand
more about the hacking that is legal and
valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story dan runs a
trading company
he does online training with the money
his customers invest
everything was going well and dan's
business was booming
until a hacker decided to hack the
company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts
he asked for a lump sum ransom in
exchange for the stolen credentials
dan took the hacker's words lightly and
didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts
and dan was liable to pay back the
customers
dan lost a lot of money and also the
trust of his customers
after this incident dan gave a lot of
thought as to what could have gone wrong
with the security infrastructure in his
company
he wished there was someone from his
company who could have run a test attack
to see how vulnerable systems were
before the hacker penetrated into the
network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker
and identifies the vulnerabilities in
his network
before an outsider does to do this job
he hired an ethical hacker john
john was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker
in no time he spotted several
vulnerabilities in dan's organization
and closed all the loopholes hiring an
ethical hacker
helped dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity
and guarded the company's reputation so
now you know hacking is not always bad
john
in this scenario expose the
vulnerabilities in the existing network
and such hacking is known as ethical
hacking
ethical hacking is distributed into six
different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how john
our ethical hacker will act before
launching an attack
the first step john takes is to gather
all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack
this step is called reconnaissance he
uses tools like
nmap and h-ping for this purpose john
then tries to spot the vulnerabilities
if any in the target system
using tools like nmap and nexpose
this is the scanning phase now that he
has located the vulnerabilities
he then tries to exploit them this step
is known
as gaining access after john makes his
way through the organization's networks
he tries to maintain his access for
future attacks by installing back doors
in the target system the metasploit tool
helps him with this this phase is called
maintaining access
john is a brilliant hacker hence he
tries his best
not to leave any evidence of his attack
this is the fifth phase
clearing tracks we now have the last
phase
that is reported in this phase john
documents a summary of his entire attack
the vulnerabilities he spotted the tools
he used
and the success rate of the attack
looking into the report
dan is now able to take a call and see
how to protect his organization
from any external cyber attacks don't
you all think
john is an asset to any organization if
you want to become an ethical hacker
like john
then there are a few skills that you
need to acquire
first and foremost you need to have a
good knowledge of operating environments
such as windows linux unix and
macintosh you must have reasonably good
knowledge of programming languages
such as html php python
sql and javascript networking is the
base of ethical hacking
hence you should be good at it ethical
hackers
should be well aware of security laws so
that they don't misuse their skills
finally you must have a global
certification on ethical hacking to
successfully bag a position of an
ethical hacker
like john few examples of ethical
hacking certification
are certified ethical hacker
certification ceh
comptia pintest plus and licensed
penetration tester certification
to name a few simply learn provides a
cyber security expert
masters program that will equip you with
all the skills required by a cyber
security expert
you could have a look at it by clicking
the link in the description
the endless growth of technologies in
this area is directly proportional to
the number of cyber crimes
cyber crimes are estimated to cost six
trillion dollars in 2021
hence to tackle these cyber crimes
organizations are continuously on the
lookout for cyber security professionals
the average annual salary of a certified
ethical hacker is ninety one thousand
dollars in the us
and approximately rupees seven lakhs in
india
so what are you waiting for get
certified and become an ethical hacker
like john
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world in this video we bring you the
top 10 computer hacks of all time
let's see what we have at number 10.
from april 27 2007
estonia the european country faced a
series of cyber attacks that lasted for
weeks
this happened when the estonian
government decided to move the bronze
soldier
from talon center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts
unprecedented levels of internet traffic
took down estonian banks online services
media outlets broadcasters and
government bodies
botnets sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated online
requests
according to researchers the public
faced ddos attacks
there were conflicts to edit the english
language version of the bronze soldiers
wikipedia page as well
although there is no confirmation russia
is believed to be behind
these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the estonian society
let's now move on to the next attack on
december 23
2015 several parts of ukraine witnessed
a power outage
and this was not a typical blackout it
was indeed the result of a cyber attack
information systems of three energy
distribution companies in ukraine were
compromised
it is the first known victorious cyber
attack on a power grid
it is said that here hackers sent out
phishing emails to the power companies
30 substations were switched off and
about 230
000 people were left in the dark for
about one to six hours
u.s investigators believed that
russia-based hackers were responsible
for this
experts have warned that other countries
could also be vulnerable to such attacks
let's see what we have at number eight
in the year 1999 a cyber attack caused a
21 day shutdown of nasa computers
unbelievable isn't it the hacker was
none other than the then 15 year old
jonathan james
he first penetrated u.s department of
defense divisions computers
and installed a back door on its servers
this allowed him to intercept more than
a thousand government emails
including the ones containing usernames
and passwords
this helped james steal a piece of nasa
software and crack the nasa computers
that support the international space
station
which cost the space exploration
agencies forty one thousand dollars
as systems were shut down for three
weeks he was the first person to carry
out a computer hack against the american
space agency
let's now move on to the next attack in
late november 2014 there was a leak of
confidential data from the film studio
of sony pictures
information about sony pictures
employees their emails copies of the
then unreleased sony films
future propositions and other crucial
data were leaked
this cyber attack was carried out by a
hacker group named guardians of peace
so what did the hackers want well they
demanded that sony withdraw its then
upcoming movie the interview
this movie was a comedy story line to
assassinate the north korean leader kim
jong-un
sony then decided to cancel the film's
theatrical release due to the threats at
cinema screening the movie
it is indeed hard to trace the roots of
a cyber attack
in this case after evaluation the u.s
intelligence officials arrived at the
theory that the attack was in a way
related to the government of north korea
however north korea had denied the same
moving on to our number six
in december 2006 tjx the u.s retailer
company
identified that 45.6 million debit and
credit card details were stolen
this happened from one of its systems
over 18 months by an unknown number of
intruders
it was one of the first largest ever
cyber attacks involving the loss of
personal data
as a result banks in the affected
regions had to reissue and block
thousands of payment cards a group of
hackers did this
albert gonzalez being the mastermind the
group was from miami the place where the
tjx heist was believed to have
originated
reports said that the tjx data breach
occurred because of weak
web encryption at two of its marshall
stores in miami
next moving on to our top five let us
see what we have at number five
the year 2010 witnessed the discovery of
the deadly computer worm stuxnet
this malware's motive was unlike any
other usual cyber attacks
it aimed at destructing the equipment
the computers controlled
stuxnet came with the deadly purpose of
damaging iran's nuclear infrastructure
it infected more than 200 000 computers
including 14 industrial sites and a
uranium enrichment plant in iran
stuxnet initially spread via microsoft
windows and targeted siemens industrial
control systems
although it was discovered only in 2010
it is believed to have been silently
sabotaging iran's nuclear facilities
it was one of the first discovered
malware that was capable of hampering
hardware systems
it largely damaged the centrifuge of the
iranian reactors
this is believed to be a cyber weapon
created by the us and the israeli
intelligence
although there is no documented evidence
or acceptance by either of the countries
for the same
moving on to number four in the year
2014
home depot was the victim of one of the
deadliest cyber attacks
56 million payment cards were
compromised along with 53 million
customer email
is stolen this security breach happened
from april to september 2014.
criminals were believed to have used a
third party vendor's username and
password to enter the perimeter of home
depos network
the attackers were then able to deploy
custom built malware on its
self-checkout systems in the us
and canada moving on to our top three
as you might be aware the playstation
gaming system is one of sony's most
popular products
unfortunately in april 2011 sony
executives witnessed abnormal activity
on the playstation network
this resulted in the compromise of
approximately 77 million playstation
users accounts
and prevented users of playstation 3 and
playstation portable consoles from
accessing this service
this forced sony to turn off the
playstation network on april 20th
on may 4th sony confirmed that
personally identifiable information
from each of the 77 million accounts had
been exposed
the outage lasted for 23 days sony
released almost daily announcements
concerning the system outage
in the end sony is believed to have
invested approximately 170 million
dollars
to improve the network security to
investigate the attack and to cover the
expenses of caring for the consumers
that had been affected
let's now move on to the next attack at
number two in may 2017 one of the most
dangerous cyber attacks took place it
was known as the wannacry ransomware
attack
caused by the wannacry crypto worm the
victims were the users that used the
unsupported version of microsoft windows
and those who hadn't installed the new
security update
this did not take place through fishing
like other attacks but
through an exposed vulnerable smb port
the attack originated in asia and then
eventually spread across the globe
in a day more than 200 000 computers
were infected across 150 countries
the wannacry crypto worm locked the
users out of the targeted systems
and encrypted their data the users were
asked for a ransom of 300 to 600 dollars
which had to be paid via bitcoin in
exchange for their data
this attack took a toll on both private
and government organizations
it resulted in damages from hundreds of
millions to billions of dollars
in a matter of few days the emergency
patches released by microsoft halted the
attack
also the discovery of a kill switch
prevented the infected computers from
spreading the crypto worm
security experts in a few countries
believed that north korea was behind
this attack
and finally let's see what we have at
number one
more than two decades ago in march 1999
the melissa virus a mass mailing macro
virus was released
it targeted microsoft word and outlook
based systems and created considerable
network traffic melissa virus infected
computers via emails
the email would look like an important
message well yes it was fake
if the recipient opens the attachments
in the mail and downloads the document
and then opens it with microsoft word
a virus was released on their computers
this would then mass mail itself to the
first 50 people in the victims contact
list
and then disable multiple safeguard
features on microsoft word and microsoft
outlook
this began spreading like a wildfire
across the internet
david l smith released the virus the
virus caused nearly 80 million worth of
damages
it did not steal data or money however
it caused a havoc
almost 1 million email accounts were
disrupted worldwide
agencies were overloaded and some had to
be shut down entirely
and internet traffic in some locations
were slowed down
hacking is a very interesting term that
most of you might have come across
it is a method by which you exploit a
network to gain access to crucial
information
when the art of hacking is used
rightfully you can prevent various cyber
attacks just like how ethical hackers
safeguard our networks
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another exciting video by simply learn
in this video we bring you the best
programming languages for hacking
here we will give you the top 5
programming languages that will help you
enhance your hacking skills
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting tech
videos every day
so let's get started first let's
understand the importance of knowing
programming for hacking
you might wonder if programming is a
necessity to become a hacker
as you might be aware hacking involves
breaking the protocols and exploiting a
network
thus being a hacker requires you to
understand the languages of the software
that you are focusing on
hence it is required that a hacker knows
coding having zero coding knowledge will
definitely limit your opportunities in
the future
knowing different programming languages
is undoubtedly an asset for hackers
everyone wants to become a hacker today
however it is not as easy as it is shown
in numerous movies
it takes plenty of practice and
programming knowledge to become an
ethical hacking expert
if you want to become a hacker it is
imperative that you have a knack for
programming languages
it is a known fact that some of the
world's best hackers started off as
programmers
if you know how to program you will be
able to dissect a code and analyze it
you can write your scripts or malware
that can be used on the victim
yes there are several ready-made scripts
available today
however you might need to apply your
skills in case the available scripts
don't work well for you
sometimes when script modification is
required you should be in a position to
do that
in such a scenario zero knowledge of the
respective programming language will
definitely be a hindrance
programs can also help you automate
multiple tasks which would normally take
a lot of time
codes allow you to penetrate different
fields you want to hack
it will help you identify the plan
behind an attack and defend against
deadly hacking techniques and make your
cyber security career worthwhile
it will help you understand the working
of the target system or application
before carrying out an exploit
now that we have an idea as to why
programming is important for hackers
let us understand which programming
languages should a hacker learn
there are several programming languages
for hacking and it might be overwhelming
to choose from the endless list
here we are to help you with that do
keep in mind that your choice of
programming language will also depend on
the type of system you are targeting and
your strategy
let us now move on to the list of the
top programming languages that are
extensively used by hackers around the
world
as you see on your screens here we have
the top 5 programming languages for
hackers
let us go through them one by one number
one
on our list is one of the most popular
programming languages today that is
python
python is a general purpose programming
language and in the field of hacking it
is mainly used for exploit writing
it is referred to as the de facto
hacking programming language
it plays a crucial role in writing
hacking scripts exploits and malicious
programs
one great feature that makes hacking
easy with python is the availability of
ready-made modules
for example os modules are available if
the target is a native operating system
for networking there is a socket module
and a lot more
python socket programming can be used
for discovering vulnerabilities in a
system since python code helps in
checking the security integrity of
systems
and it can also be used to exploit them
python has a massive community that
helps with third-party plugins every day
it is also an easy to read language with
a simple syntax
this will be helpful for beginners you
can easily write automation scripts
using python and it also makes
prototyping much faster
moving on to our second programming
language we have javascript
currently javascript is one of the best
programming languages for hacking web
applications
a good understanding of javascript
allows a hacker to discover
vulnerabilities and carry web
exploitation
since most of their web apps use
javascript or one of its libraries
knowing javascript will help you
discover flaws in web applications
javascript can be used to read saved
cookies and security experts also use
javascript to develop cross-site
scripting programs for hacking
javascript is known for carrying out
attacks like cross-site scripting
javascript can also be used to spread
and reproduce malware and viruses
easily initially javascript was a
client-side scripting language
however with the release of node.js it
now supports back-end development
this implies a larger field for
exploitation
a hacker can now use javascript to snoop
the type towards
inject malicious code and track browsing
history to name a few
number three on our list is php
hypertext preprocessor or php is a
dynamic server-side programming language
that is used to build websites hackers
should understand php as it will help
them understand web hacking techniques
better
especially if you're into web hacking
then getting your hands on php would be
an asset
php is used in server-side scripting
using php you could write a custom
application that modifies settings on a
web server
and makes a target server susceptible to
attacks
with the help of php you can also
eliminate any vulnerabilities in your
code
php is one of the most powerful server
side languages used in most of their web
domains
this shows how learning php can help you
with web hacking and also help you fight
against malicious attackers
popular content management systems run
on a foundation of php
hence having a strong knowledge of php
can help you protect or compromise such
websites
next on a list of the best programming
languages for hackers is sql
sql is the acronym for structured query
language
although sql is not a traditional
programming language it is a language
used for only communicating with
databases
several systems like mysql postgresql
store
their data in databases sql is used to
interact with such databases
in order to organize add retrieve delete
or edit
data from a database having an in-depth
knowledge of sql lets you comprehend the
structure of a database
thereby helping you decide which scripts
or tools to deploy
sql is used for the purpose of web
hacking sql is undoubtedly the best
programming language when it comes to
hacking into large databases
it will be impossible to contract
database attacks without a good
understanding of sql
using sql hackers can perform an attack
known as sql injection attack
such an attack enables hackers to access
confidential information from databases
sql is used by hackers to develop
various hacking programs based on sql
injection
sql injection is used to bypass web
application
login algorithms that are weak such an
attack can also help a hacker
view and modify confidential information
from databases
finally at number 5 we have the c
programming language
it is no surprise that we have c the
mother of all programming languages on
our list
it is used massively in the security
field it helps with exploit writing and
development
the low-level nature of c provides an
edge over other programming languages
used for hacking
a hacker can use the c programming
language to his or her advantage when it
comes to accessing low-level hardware
components such as the ram
security professionals mostly uc when
they are required to manipulate system
resources
and hardware c also helps penetration
testers write programming scripts
most operating systems and computer
programs are coded in c
language hence learning c you will help
hackers get an overview of the structure
of operating systems
c is also used to create shell codes
root kits exploits build
undetectable malware key loggers and
much more
sometimes it is also advisable to learn
both c and c plus plus as they both come
in handy for hackers
so those were our top five programming
languages for hackers
do keep in mind that the most important
step of becoming a hacker is to learn
various programming languages
it will be great if you can master a
variety of programming languages as your
target will not be the same always
on that note in addition to previously
mentioned programming languages
we have an additional list of languages
that are also well recognized for
hacking
let's have a look at our honorary
mention first
we have ruby the ruby programming
language has been used for exploitation
for quite some time now
there can be a close comparison drawn
between ruby and python based on its
syntax
however ruby is more web focused
ruby can be used to write either small
or large scripts and can be used
interchangeably with bash scripting
it offers good flexibility while writing
exploits
ruby has been used by several hackers to
exploit corporate systems
it is not that easy to master ruby and
that is one reason why mncs look for
professionals who know ruby
second we have pearl although pearl has
lost its old fame it still holds value
in the hacker community for exploit
writing
there are systems that still run on perl
as it was the go to solution once
it is a great language that can help you
manipulate linux text files and help you
create tools and exploits
perl code bases still do occupy a
considerable portion of corporate tools
third on our list is html many of you
might have wondered why we didn't
mention html yet
yes no programming list is complete
without mentioning html
the hypertext markup language html is a
standard markup language used for
creating web pages
it glows the whole internet together and
it is the language of the web
this shows the importance html has an
understanding of
html is vital to play with web
applications
html also finds its use in developing
hybrid mobile and desktop apps
html is a must if you want to master
this field
having said that html is not that tough
a language to learn
hence it is advised to master html if
you want to compromise web applications
and finally at 4 we have assembly level
language
it is undoubtedly one of the most
powerful yet hardest programming
languages to learn
it is a complicated low-level
programming language
for hacking primitive systems assembly
is one of the best programming languages
the best part of assembly is that you
can instruct machine hardware or
software using it
assembly language helps a hacker
manipulate systems straight up at the
architecture level
it is also the most suited coding
language to build malware like viruses
and trojans
it is considered to be the best language
for jobs that are time critical
reverse engineers use assembly language
for example if you're interested in
software cracking and if you want to
reverse engineer a piece of software
that has already been compiled
assembly is the go to choice as
complicated as a language sounds the
results it produces are highly fruitful
so those were the additional programming
languages that can help you become a
skilled and
successful hacker we should keep in mind
that a strong understanding of
programming languages help cyber
security professionals stay on top of
cyber criminals
let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is
hacking refers to exploiting weaknesses
in a computer network
to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some key words that we
need to understand
first and foremost exploit when you are
exploiting weaknesses
weaknesses are technically called
vulnerabilities which are basically
design flaws
misconfiguration errors usage of default
usernames and passwords which
have not been modified so any
misconfiguration
or anything that has been left behind by
a security administrator that can be
misused
which means exploited by a hacker to
gain unauthorized access
so the next term is unauthorized access
something that you are not allowed to do
and when you say a hacker is a person
who tries to hack it's basically
a person with malicious intent trying to
gain access
to a system or a resource that they are
not authorized to access in the first
place how do they do it
they find a vulnerability that is a
weakness or a flaw and then they misuse
it to gain access
to that particular network so here in
the diagram you can see that a sender
on the left hand side is trying to send
some data to the receiver on the right
hand side
the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets within
let's look at a business case scenario
into hacking now there is an
organization
everybody is going around their own
business when they realize that their
systems may have been compromised now
they're trying to look at the customer
data to ensure that that has not been
compromised and
trying to assure the customers however
they do realize
that some customer data has been lost
and even
the company reports have been modified
as well now this is the scenario where
there have been some security controls
in place and those controls have been
identified
they realized that there is an attack
that has happened and based on that
attack
they have realized that the data has now
been compromised and the records have
been modified
by the hacker which means that the data
is no longer trustworthy
and thus cannot be used by the business
for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or
gets connected to the organization
demanding a ransom for the data to be
replaced to be taken back into the
original state where it was trusted
and thus the organization can utilize it
for business transactions
the organization has probably no backup
so they decide that they want to
pay the lump sum to the hacker to
restore that data so that they can
continue on with the business
does money exchanges and the hacker is
able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however
the activity here of a hacker trying to
leverage
the misconfiguration of the weaknesses
in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and make these ransomware demands so the
company then
wants to figure out even if having a
security system in place
how was the hacker able to hack their
systems thus
one of the employees comes up with a
brilliant idea of identifying
vulnerabilities
in the network uh to proactively search
for any flaws that have been left behind
so that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them
thus they figure out that they want to
hire an ethical hacker
who would help them identify the
security portion of the organization
identify the weaknesses
vulnerabilities and flaws and help them
remedy those flaws so that
in future scenarios these scenarios will
not happen
so before we go into an ethical hacker
let's understand what are the types of
hackers so
what are the types of hackers hacker is
a technically skilled person
who is very adept with computers they
have good
programming skills they understand how
operating system works they understand
how networks work they understand how to
identify flaws and vulnerabilities
within all of these aspects and then
they understand and know how to misuse
these flaws
to get a outcome which would be
detrimental to the health of the
organization
so there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers
white hat hackers grey hat script
kiddies nation's players sponsored
hackers
and hacktivists so black hat hackers are
basic basically
the malicious hackers who have malicious
intent
and have criminalistic tendencies they
want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective
these guys are also known as crackers
the main aspect of these
people are that they have malicious
intent they try to do unauthorized
activities
and they try it for personal gain
another important aspect to remember is
that a black hat hacker will always try
to hide their identity
uh they'll spoof their online digital
identity by masking it by
spoofing their ip addresses mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a white attacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who is an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a black hat hacker would do
minus the malicious intent plus the
intent of helping the organization
identifying the flaws and remedying them
so that nobody else can misuse those
vulnerabilities so they are authorized
to act on the company's behalf
they are authorized to do that activity
which would help the company identify
those flaws
and thus help the company mitigate those
flaws improving on their security
portion
so these these kind of security experts
or ethical hackers
would help organizations defend
themselves against unauthorized attacks
grey hat hackers is a blend of both
white hat and black hat hackers
so here they can work defensively and
offensively both
they can accept contracts from
organizations to increase
their security posture at the same time
they can also get themselves involved in
malicious activities towards other
organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity
script kitties are people uh who are
technically
not much aware about what hacking is uh
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers
they have no technical knowledge of what
they're doing it's just a hit or miss
for them so they just get
their hands on a tool they try to
execute those tools uh if the hack works
it works otherwise it doesn't so these
people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or
uh just uh people who with malicious
intent who just want to have some fun
or trying to impress people around then
we have the nation
or the state-sponsored hackers as the
name suggests these hackers are
sponsored by their government
now this may not be a legitimate job but
most of the governments do have
uh hackers uh enrolled in their pay on
uh
on their organizations to spy on their
enemies to spy on various countries
and try to figure out the aspirations of
those countries so this is basically a
spying activity
where you are technically trying to get
access to other countries resources
and then try to spy on them to figure
out what their activities have been
or what their future plans have been and
then we have the hacktivist
who's an individual who has a political
agenda to promote
and they promote it by doing hacking so
these guys what is the difference
between a black hat hacker and a
hacktivist the black hat
hacker may try to hide their identity a
hacktivist
will claim responsibility of what they
have done so for them it's a political
agenda political cause
and they will try to hack various
organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website
and posting the messages that they want
to promote on these websites
so what exactly is ethical hacking then
we have discussed the types of hackers
we have identified a malicious hacker as
a black hat hacker
with the intent of doing harm to an
organization's network
for personal gain we have discussed what
the ethical hacker is so an ethical
hacker
would be doing the same activity but in
an authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization
it would give them a definite scope of
what they are allowed to do and what
they are not allowed to do
and the ethical hackers would function
within those scopes would try to execute
those
test scenarios where they would be able
to identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities
and then they would be submitting a
report to the management of what they
have found they would also help the
management
to mitigate or to resolve those
weaknesses so that nobody else
can misuse them later on they might use
the same techniques and the same
tools that black hat hackers do however
the main difference here is that these
guys are authorized to do that
particular activity
they're doing it in a controlled manner
with the intent of helping the
organization
and not with the intent of personal
gains so who's an ethical hacker
again an ethical hacker is a highly
intelligent highly educated person who
knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
adept
at computing they understand the
architecture they understand
how various components in a computer
work they can troubleshoot those
components
and they can basically be very good with
programming
as well now when i say programming we
don't want the ethical hacker to be a
good developer of applications
we want them to understand programming
in such a way that they can create
scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
trojans or exploits which should help
them achieve
the objective that they have set out for
so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of
concerned authorities so what is the
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization
by identifying what security controls
are in place how they have been
configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves
so an organization will hire a heckler
hacker they they would give the ethical
hacker the information
about what information is or what
security controls
what firewalls now what idss ipss
introgen detection or intuition
prevention systems antiviruses are
already in place and then they will ask
the ethical hacker to figure out a way
to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization
what is the need of an ethical hacker
the need of an ethical hacker is
proactive security the ethical hacker
would identify
all the existing flaws in an
organization and
try to resolve those laws to help secure
the organization
from black hat hackers so ethical
hackers would prevent hackers from
cracking into an organization's network
by securing the organization by
improving on their security
on a periodic basis and they would also
try to identify system vulnerabilities
network vulnerabilities or application
level vulnerabilities that would have
been missed or have already been missed
and then tried to figure out a way of
plugging them or
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers
they would also analyze and enhance an
organization security policies
now what are policies policies are
basically documents that have been
created by an organization
of rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained
for example a password policy a password
policy
would help users in an organization to
adhere to
the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example
a password when a user is creating them
should adhere to standards where they
are using
random words they are they contain the
alphabet a through z
uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9 as
numerics and special characters
and they're randomized so that the
password becomes much more stronger to
prevent from brute force attacks
so what would an ethical hacker do at
this point in time they would try to
test
the strength of the passwords to see if
brute force attacks or dictionary
attacks are possible
and if any of these passwords can be
cracked they will ensure that
all the employees are following the
policies and all the passwords are
as secured as the policies want them to
be if there are any gaps
in the policies or the implementation of
the policy it is the ethical hacker's
responsibility to identify those gaps
and warn the organization about it
similarly they would also try to protect
any personal information any data that
is owned by the organization that is
critical for the functioning of the
organization
and they will try to protect it by from
falling into
the hackers hands now what are the
skills that are required of an ethical
hacker these are the following skills so
first and foremost they should have
good knowledge with operating systems
such as windows linux
unix and mac now when we say knowledge
about operating systems it's not only
about how to use those operating systems
were how to troubleshoot
those operating systems how these
operating systems work how these
operating systems need to be configured
how can they be secured for example
securing an operating system is not only
installing a firewall and an antivirus
but you need to configure permissions on
an operating system of what users are
allowed to do and what users are not
allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system
center the security center of windows
and we need to configure security
parameters over there
of what are acceptable softwares and
what are not same with linux
and mac softwares operating systems so
we need to know
how we can secure these operating
systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know
the desktop and server versions both how
to configure them and how to provide
services within the organization
on these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be
knowledgeable of programming languages
or scripting languages such as php
python
ruby html for programming if you will
because web servers come into the
picture so again
they should not be great developers
where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts
understand those scripts analyze those
scripts and figure out what the output
should be of those scripts to achieve
the
hacking goals that they have set out for
an ethical hacker should have a very
good understanding about networking
no matter whether you're in application
security you're in network security or
you're in host-based security
since a computer will always be
connected to a network either a local
area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the osi model we should
know which protocols work
on those seven layers we should identify
the tcp model and how
osi model can be mapped to the tcp model
we should understand how tcp and udp
work how
how each and every protocol is crafted
how they are supposed to behave
for us to analyze and understand any
network based attacks
we should be very good in security
measures so we should know
where those vulnerabilities would lie
what are the latest exploits available
in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools
of how to deal with security how to
analyze security
and then how to implement security to
enhance it as well
along with that it is important that a
security analyst or ethical hacker is
aware of the local security laws and
standards
why is that because an organization
cannot do any illegal activity
whatever responses that they have
whatever security mechanisms whatever
security controls they will implement
they need to be
adhering to the local law of the land
they should be legal in nature
and should not cause undue harm to any
of the employees or any of the
third party clients that they are
dealing with so the ethical hackers
should be aware of what
security laws are before they implement
security controls or even
before they start testing for security
controls and all of these should be
backed up by having a global
certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical hacking the
law of the land
anything and everything maybe even
programming it's good to have a
certification in php perl python ruby
and so on so forth why because most of
the organizations when they hire ethical
hackers
look out for these certifications
especially globally valid certifications
so that they can be sure or they can be
assured that the person that they are
hiring
has the required skill set so let's talk
about a few of the tools that a ethical
hacker
would utilize in the testing scenarios
to be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there
what you see on the screen are just a
few examples of them
nessus is a vulnerability scanner what
is a vulnerability scanner
it is an automated tool that is designed
to identify vulnerabilities
within hosts within operating systems
within networks
so they come with their ready-made
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified
and the scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners
like acunetix or arachne that would help
you scan applications and identify flaws
within those applications as well
now all of these are automated tools the
essence of ethical hacker is when these
tools churn out the reports the ethical
hacker can understand these reports
analyze them
identify the flaws and then craft their
own exploits
or use existing exploits in a particular
manner
so that they can get access or they can
bypass the access
or security controls mechanisms that are
already in place how can they do that
with the tool called metasploit you see
that big m there on the right hand side
that m logo is for a tool called
metasploit which is a penetration
testing tool
what is a penetration testing tool it is
that tool that will allow an ethical
hacker to craft their exploits or choose
their exploits for the vulnerabilities
that have been identified by nessus
since we are interacting with computers
we will always be interacting using
tools
right so the first tool nessus
identifies the flaws and the possible
list of vulnerabilities
we do a penetration test using
metasploit to validate those flaws and
to verify that those laws are
actually exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws
and that's where metasploit helps us do
that wireshark would be used in the
background
while we are doing both the activities
using nessus or metasploit to keep a
track of what packets are being sent
and by received on the network which
will help us analyze those packets
so whenever i run an ss scanner i would
run a wireshark in the background it
will capture the data packets
and i can go through those data packets
and analyze that data packets to
identify
what nessus is actually trying to do
similarly when i try to attack a machine
using exploit on metasploit i will keep
on
wireshark running in the background to
capture the data package that have been
sent
and the responses that i've received
from the victim so that i can also go
through those packets
and analyze the responses and analyze
the attack whether it was successful
to what extent was it successful and
basically will
also give me a validation of proof of
the activity that has happened
nmap is another automated tool that
allows me to scan
for open ports and protocols so why
would i use nmap
because pro ports and protocols become
an entry point
for a hacker to gain access to devices
for example when we connect to a web
server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to port 80 using
http
and port 443 is using https so if i am
connecting to a web server
using https it is safe to assume that
port 443
on the web server is open to accept
those connections
similarly there would be other services
that may be left open on the web server
because nobody thought about configuring
it or they misconfigured the web server
and they left unwanted services running
so nmap will allow me to scan those
ports and services
and allow me to understand what services
are being offered on that server
so then i can start analyzing that
server identify those flaws within those
services
and then try to attack them if the
application that i'm analyzing
is connected to a database and i want to
do a sql injection attack or
if i if necess tells me that there is a
sequel injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
i can use an automated tool called sql
map or sql map
that would allow me to automatically
craft all the queries that are required
for a sql injection attack and help me
do that attack at the same time
so here i do not have to manually create
my own queries
uh the sql map tool would automatically
create
them for me what i would do is i would
use nessus to identify that particular
flaw if nessus reports that flaw i would
then go
use the tool sql map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when i fire off the tool
it will then automatically start
directing queries sql injection queries
to the database to see if those
databases are vulnerable and if yes what
data can be retrieved from those
databases
so all of these tools in a nutshell
would help me
hack networks applications operating
systems and host devices
and this is what the ethical hacker does
they use these kind of tool sets they
identify what
attacks they need to do they identify
the right tool for that particular
attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management
providing them feedback about how the
attack was created
or crafted what was the response to that
attack and whether the attack was
successful or not if successful they
would also give recommendations
of what to do to prevent these attacks
from happening
in the future so when we are doing these
attacks
or when we want to launch these attacks
what is the process that
we would follow so there are six steps
that we would do
as an ethical hacker if you are just a
hacker you probably wouldn't do the
sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
reconnaissance phase which is the
information gathering phase
which is very important from ethical
hackers perspective or a hacker's
perspective
because if i want to attack someone or
something as a digital device
i need to know what i'm attacking i need
to know the ip address of the device the
mac address of those devices
i need to know the operating system the
build or the version of that operating
systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so i know what i'm
attacking
for example if i if i want to attack a
server i assume it's a windows based
server
and i use a particular tool to attack it
but it actually turns out to be a linux
based server
my attacks are going to be unsuccessful
so i need to focus my attack
based on what is there at the other end
so in my information gathering phase i
want to identify
all of that information once i have that
information done i'm going to scan those
servers
using tools like nmap that we just
talked about and we're going to try to
see
the open ports open services and
protocols that are running on that
server
that can give me possible entry points
within
the network or within the device or
within the operating system
at the same time along with the scanning
with nmap i would run
a vulnerability scanner the necess
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acunetix for applications
and then i will try to identify
vulnerabilities in those applications
operating systems or networks
once i have identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase i
would then move on to the gaining phase
where i would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the
attacking the victim at this point in
time if my attack is successful i will
probably have gained access
by either tracking passwords or
escalating privileges
or exploiting a vulnerability that i may
have found during the scanning phase
once i have gained my access i want to
maintain my access
why because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist
or existing or somebody changed the
password that we i may have cracked
does i no longer have access so what do
i do to maintain my access
i install trojans or backdoor entries to
those systems using which
i can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices
at my own will at my own time as long as
those devices are available over the
network
so that's where i maintain my access i
have hacked them now i want to maintain
my access so i install a software
which would give me a backdoor entry to
that device no matter what
once i have done this i want to clear my
track so whatever activity that i've
been doing for example installing a
trojan
a trojan is also a software that would
create directory directories and files
once installed on the victim's
machine so i want to hide that if i have
access data stores if i have modified
data
i want to hide that activity because if
the victim comes to know that something
has happened
they would start they would start
increasing their security parameters
they might start scanning their devices
they may take them offline
thus my hack would no longer be
efficient the reason i'm clearing my
tracks
is that the victim doesn't find out that
they have been hacked or they have been
compromised or even if they do find out
that they've been compromised
they cannot trace the compromise back to
me so i would be deleting references of
any of the ip addresses or mac addresses
that i may have used to attack that
particular device
and this is where i will be able to
identify where those logs were created
where those
traces are once i take off those traces
the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised
or who compromised their system and if i
am successful at all of these stages or
what to whatever extent
the success that i've achieved in any of
these stages i would then create a
report based on that and i would report
to the management about the activities
that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example
we identified 10 different flaws there
were 20 different attacks that we wanted
to do
what attack did we do what was the
outcome of that attack
what was the intended or the expected
output of that attack i'll create a
report which would give a detailed
analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences
of what activity was conducted what was
the output what was the expected output
and i would submit that report to the
management
giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be mitigated
so that the security can be enhanced so
these are the six steps that the ethical
hacking
process would take uh just going through
this the uh recognizance is where you're
going to use hacking tools like nmap hp
to obtain information about targets
there are hundreds of tools out there
depending on what information you want
then in scanning again
nmap nexpose these kind of tools to be
utilized to identify open ports
protocols and services
in gaining access you're going to
exploit the vulnerability by using the
metasploit tool that we talked about in
the previous slides
in the maintaining access you're going
to install backdoors
you can use metasploit at the same time
you can craft your own scripts
to create a trojan and install it on the
victims machine
once you have achieved that clearing
tracks is where you're going to clear
all evidences
of your activity so that you do not get
caught or the victim doesn't even
realize that they have been hacked
and once you have done all of this we
are going to create reports
that are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization
so now let's see how we can hack using
social engineering now what is social
engineering
social engineering is the art of
manipulating humans
into revealing confidential information
which they otherwise would not have
revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you are able to communicate
effectively to another person
they would probably give up more
information that they intended to give
out
let's take a look at examples right if
you see on the screen
fishing activity what is phishing we
receive a lot of frequents on a regular
basis
we have always received those emails
where we have won a lottery of a few
million dollars
but we have never realized that we
didn't purchase a lottery to win a
lottery in the first place
we have always had those nigerian frauds
where
a prince died in some south african
country and u out of seven billion
people
on the planet have been identified where
they want to transfer a few hundred
million dollars through your account and
they want to give you 50
of that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go
onto websites and there's a banner
flashing at you
saying congratulations you're the one
million visitor to this website
click here to claim your price all of
these are social engineering attacks
phishing attacks
fake websites fake communications being
sent out
to users to prey on their gullibility
most of humans
always have that dream of striking it
rich winning a huge lottery once and for
all
and living their life lavishly ever
after but sadly in the real world that's
not that doesn't happen that often
and if you're receiving those meals it
is very important that you first
research the validity of those those
communications before you even want to
act upon them
so why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotions
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a
account that you have forgotten a
password to the machine wouldn't even
know what you're doing try pleading with
a human
sympathy or empathy where you could uh
try to create a social injury attack
where you can
plead with them saying if i do not get
access to this account immediately i
might lose my job
and then that would put my family into
problems somebody would feel empathy or
sympathy towards you and help you reset
that password and give you access to
that account
it's how good the attack is and how
convincing you are
for the success of this attack to happen
so what is a familiarity exploit
attackers interact with victims to gain
information
which will benefit the attackers to
crack credentials as passwords
if we want to reset our passwords what
do we have
as a mechanism to resetting passwords we
have some security questions that we set
up those questions are nothing but
personal information that we would know
but through a social engineering attack
it would be easily be able to uh gather
the information that you have set for
your security questions the
security questions can be as simple as
the first cool that you attended you
probably have that listed on your
linkedin profile
where a person can just go in there and
see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you're in right
similarly it might also be a question
what was your mother's maiden name
that's a very good attack and that's uh
i mean if a person can interact with you
let's say they are trying to take a
survey and they approach you for a
feedback on a particular product that
you have been utilizing
and they ask you these questions you
wouldn't think twice before giving those
answers
as long as the request sounds legitimate
to us we are able to justify that
request
we do answer those queries so it's upon
us to verify the authenticity
of the request coming in before we
answer it phishing as discussed
would be fraudulent emails which appear
to be coming from a trusted source
so email spoofing comes into mind fake
websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep
pen drives lying around in a parking lot
now this is an open a generic attack
whoever falls victim will fall victim so
if i just
throw around a few usbs in the parking
lot obviously with trojans implemented
on them
some people who are curious or who are
looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives
at the same time once they plug in those
pendrives on their computers
the virus or the trojan would get
infected and cause harm to their machine
then exploiting human greed we just
talked about the
nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks
the fake money-making gimmicks now
basically this is where you
prey upon the person's agreed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to get that money that has been
promised to them in that email
so one of the safest mechanism to keep
data private and to keep yourself secure
is using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography
cryptography is the art of scrambling
data
using a particular algorithm so that the
data becomes unreadable
to the normal user the only person with
the key to unscramble that data would be
able to unscramble it
and make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the
end user the you end user using the same
key
would then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it
so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would
look like e q o r x v gt
for an end user it wouldn't make any
sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus
three so c plus three alphabets that
becomes e
o becomes q m becomes o so
the key that is utilized to scramble the
data
is the character that you are at the
third character from there
would be the corresponding key so the
encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and you can now
figure out what that e corresponding to
by going
back three characters in the alphabet
most of the times a certified ethical
hacker must decrypt a message without
knowing the secret key
so let's say a ransomware has affected
your organization
or has affected a device and you want to
figure out
uh or you want to decrypt that data now
as an ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to
try to crack the encryption mechanism
how to crack the cipher
to decrypt that message and see what's
within it right decryption without the
use of a secret key
that is known as a cryptanalysis
cryptanalysis is the
reversing of an algorithm to figure out
what the decryption was
uh without using a key so cryptanalysis
can be done using
various formats the first one is a brute
force attack
second is a dictionary attack the third
one is a rainbow table attack a brute
force attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was
it is 100 successful but may take a lot
of time
a dictionary attack is where you have
created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks
work or not rainbow tables are where you
have an
encrypted text in hand and you're trying
to figure out
uh the similarities between between the
text that you have and
the encrypted data that you wanted to
decrypt in the first place so
in the brute force attack you're trying
every possible combination permutation
of what the key would be in dictionary
attack
you have a word list that would
tantamount to the key
and if you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work
to decrypt that data here in the rainbow
table the cipher text is compared with
another cipher text you find out
similarities
and then you try to work or reverse
engineer your way accordingly so let's
have a quick demo on cryptography before
we end this session
so to begin with the demo of
cryptography we are on our website
called spammic.com
which will help us scramble the message
that we created
into a completely uh format which would
be
unrelated to the topic at hand so if i
say i want to encode a message i turn a
short message into spam so what this
does is
want to send across a secret message you
type in the secret message a short one
it will convert that into a spam mail
you send it across
so whoever is reading that spam mail
would never get an idea of the embedded
message within it
so if i want to type in a message here
hi this is a secret
message the password is
asd at the rate one two three four and i
want to send this out to people
or to one of my colleagues but i want to
send it out in a secret manner so that
others
are not aware of this so when i press on
encode what the algorithm will do is
it will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this is a secret
message the password is at the rate one
two three four
or asd at the rate one two three four
gets converted into this now if you read
it
dear e-commerce professional this letter
was specially selected to be sent to you
this doesn't make sense there is nowhere
or no reference to the actual message
that i've already
said so if i copy this entire message
and i send it let's say via email
to the recipient now the thing is that
the recipient needs to know that i've
encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm
needs to remain the same so once they
know that it is spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
open up a new browser
and i'm going to go to the same website
and at this point in time
i'm going to click on decode when i
click on decode
i'm going to paste the message that i've
just copied there we are
and this message is now being copied
into a different browser
and if i decode this you will see that
it will convert it back
to the original message that there was
so the key
is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we paste the message in the decode
factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual
message that was embedded within it
there we are the entire message
this is what we created in the google
chrome browser
and in the firefox browser we decoded
similarly if i want to protect these
kind of messages
there is an aspen encrypt.com website
where let's say
we use text encryption and i want to
encrypt the same message
this is a secret message
the password is asd at the rate one two
three four
and then i give it a password to protect
this message let's say the word password
and i use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say aes which is the
strongest cipher right now and i say
encrypt
so this is what the encryption would
look like and basically
uh if i don't have the password over
here if i decrypt it you would see that
the error has occurred
if i type in the password over here and
then decrypt it it will be able to
convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
asd at the rate one two three four
so if i want to keep my data secure from
hackers
i want to scramble it in such a way that
they would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult
for them to crack it and this is one of
the first mechanisms
that would be recommended by any ethical
hacker to keep the data secure now let's
talk about downloading and installing
kali linux
along with that we'll also be looking at
the basic commands that are required for
kali linux
alright so i've opened my browser and we
want to go to the kali website so we
want to go to kali.org
you can directly type in kali.org and go
to the website
i can just do a google search and say
kali download
and it will give you the same website
but it will directly take you to the
downloads pages
so either here and or you can go to the
home page
cookies are being installed on your
machine so see which cookies you want to
allow i'm only going to use the
necessary cookies
to support this site and you can see
that this gives you the latest kali
linux
news and tutorials gives you the latest
release what is in that release
and gives you a lot of documentation
which will help you understand what
tools
have been developed and what
functionality has been given in the
latest version
if you want to download you can directly
go here and you can
download kali linux now kali linux is a
2.6 gigabyte download so it's going to
take time the latest version being
2019.4
and we click over here i'm using a
download manager to manage all these
huge downloads
and you can see it's pointed to the
operating systems folder
and it is going to be a 2.57 gb
download so you click on download and in
the background
you can see this is going to be
downloaded and you're going to minimize
this
and it will take a few minutes for that
to download but this is an iso image so
we need to install it on a virtual
machine
so what we need is we need to use a
hypervisor which will allow us to create
virtual machines so we can either use
vmware workstation
which you can download from here however
this is
paid version so you can see it is around
250
or something for this software but it is
a very good software to have so if you
click on download now
it is going to start the download it's a
30-day trial period
if you want to use it after 30 days
you'll need to enter the key
which you'll get after purchasing the
software if you do not want to utilize
this
the free version that you have you can
either download
vmware player but there are some
limitations for vmware player that you
might want to look at
does you want to compare these products
before you want to purchase them
right otherwise you can download oracle
virtualbox
which is a free hypervisor it's not as
robust as vmware workstation
but it does the trick right so the the
free version
6.1 is free and you can then create your
own
virtual machines over there and install
operating systems on them
what i do have i already have a vmware
workstation installed so i'm just going
to open that up
and that's my vmware workstation as you
can see i already have a lot of virtual
machines created over here
what we're going to do is we're going to
configure a virtual machine for the kali
linux
operating system that we are downloading
which should be somewhere here
let's see it's at 43 percent so
halfway there till then let's create the
virtual machine so i click click on file
create a new virtual machine i'm going
to customize the
machine so click on next this little
default we don't want to change that
and then we want to install the
operating system later we don't want to
point it out right now so i'll just
click on i will install the operating
system later
click on next we want to install linux
now in the drop down you would not see
kali linux over here however you can
choose
ubuntu 64-bit that's what i'm going to
choose
there it is next what is the name that
we want
i want to give it kali linux without the
typo
and i want to store it in one of the
folders that i've created
by default it stores on the c drive
which is not a good place to store
uh you don't want to run out of space on
your c drive so i'm going to click on
this pc
and this is my data and
in here i'll have a folder called
virtualbox or virtual machines there it
is
within which you can see the other
softwares that i already created
i'm going to create a new folder and
call it kali 2019
l l for it is latest for me because you
can see already have a kali linux so i'm
just going to identify this folder with
the l
at the end going to select it and click
on ok you can see the path being changed
over here
click on next it's going to ask you how
many processors now depending on the
processor that you have
you can see i've got a 8 core i7 so if i
give it 16 cores or 16 processors that's
not going to work
i cannot go beyond what the physicality
already is
so for this machine one processor with
one core is more than enough
if you're going to load use a lot of
tools at the same time you might just
want to give it two cores
so given it two cores it will ask us
for ram to be provided for this virtual
machine by default 2048 megabytes that's
2gb of ram is more than enough
if you require more we can change this
later on so click on next
we want to use nat for now leave this
default next
whatever is recommended keep it the way
it is we do not want to change it
next create a new virtual hard disk for
this machine
and it is going to ask us the size 20 gb
is more than fine store it as a single
file
you don't want to use multiple file
options click on next
and then click on browse wherever you
want to store the vmdk file
or the virtual hard disk file and we go
back again to the same folder that we
had created
virtual machines and we look at the
kali linux kali 2019 l and we want to
store the
vmdk file over there once we save it we
want to click on next
and then we want to click on finish so
this is the virtual machine that has
been created right here
right now this is the basic
configuration now where are we at with
the operating system
and you can see the operating system has
been downloaded and it is
stored in this particular folder so we
go to e drive
so we are looking for the operating
system that we have downloaded we
downloaded in the
operating systems folder and if we go in
here you can see the
current one the kali linux 2019.4
iso right here so what we do we go back
to the kali linux machine that we have
created
edit virtual machine settings and we
point this virtual machine
using the cd dvd and then we point the
iso
the one that we downloaded over here so
we go back to e drive we go back to os
and we click on kali linux 2019 click on
open
so now when this boots up it will boot
up with this iso and then
it will allow us to install the
operating system so click on ok
then we click on power on this virtual
machine it will start powering on
it will boot to the iso and it will
start giving us the booting
option so i'm just going to enter the
full screen mode over here
for this to be better visible and we
don't want the live mode what we want is
we want to use the graphical install
and then we highlight that we press
enter and you can see the setup starting
up
we'll wait for the gui to pop up there
it is which language do we want for now
we want english
click on continue where are we located
click on continue
and the configure your keyboard we
want the us keyboard american english
continue it is going to detect the
hardware so as you can see on the screen
it's attempting a
auto configuration for most of these uh
settings the network with dhcp it has
identified
the network cards uh hardware like uh
the processor
that has been provided but it's asking
for a host name we're going to leave it
at default
we're going to click on continue domain
name i'm not
joining this into a domain as yet
there's going to be a standalone machine
so i can leave this blank
click on continue now it is going to
configure the network it is asking for a
password
at this point in time the root password
type in any password that you want
ensure that you remember the password
now by default the username for the
account is the name is the word root we
are just creating the password for the
root account
and then we want to click on continue
setting up the clock looking at the hard
disks
now here it asks us do you want to use
the entire disk the 20gb virtual hard
disk that we had provided or do we want
to give it a manual
configuration or a guided one where we
want encryption
and a logical volume management coming
into the picture we're just going to use
the first option guided you
use entire disk don't worry it's only
going to use the virtual disk that we
had created
click on continue it will give us that
it's a 21.5 gb
vmware virtual disk that we had and
click on continue
all files in one partition that's what
we want recommended for new users
whatever it is we don't want to change
these folders
continue and this is what we have
configured once we click on continue it
is going to say
you are you sure you want to make these
changes click on yes
click on continue and it will start
installing kali linux on your
device now this is going to take a few
minutes for the installation to work
all right so that's the installation
that's completed now it's asking us to
configure a package manager a network
mirror can be used to supplement the
software
that is included on the installation
media this may also make new versions of
software available you want to use a
network mirror we can click
no for now and then click on continue
now this is going to install the grub
bootloader this might take a few minutes
as well install the group
grub loader to the master boot record
yes click on
continue click the hard disk that you
have just utilized
this is the one click on continue it
will install the grub book loader
running through the last
phases of the installation and now it
says the installation is complete we
want to click click on continue
finishing the installation and then it
will do a reboot
all right and you can see this is
starting up so we are going to use you
just wait
out the boot and now it started the
booting sequence
just going to maximize the screen and
you can see it's asking me for the
password there's the one that we created
now
that's the that's not the password
that's the username that's the root
and the password that we had created at
that point in time
and then click on log in and this is
your screen
uh now what we need to do here is we
need to install
vmware tools which will help us manage
the screen
and help the virtual machine to be a
little bit better
integrated on the system so that's not
mounted yet so we're just waiting for it
to mount
there it is and what we want to do here
is open vmware tools upgrader all right
so what we want is we want to
extract or we want to use this open x
archiver and
once we do that we'll see the vmware
install dot pl
double click on that all right we've got
the vmware tools here what i've done is
we have
extract2 and i've extracted that on the
desktop
right so what we just did was click on
the desktop over here
open and this is what it will do and
click on extract
now there is happening because i've
already extracted this open this up we
want to run
this vmware install dot pl so what do we
do we open up the terminal window
which is the command line interface over
here and now this is where some of the
commands come into the picture
so for example pwd will show us the
present working directory
ls will show us the list of the folders
they are there so
the folder that we have is on our
desktop so we'll just change
directory to desktop press enter do an
ls that will show us the list and you
can see vmware tools this trip that's
the folder that we have right here right
so we want to go into that
folder see the vmware at this point you
can just click on tab
and it will populate everything over
there press enter do an ls
and we want the vm where hyphen
install dot pl to be executed all right
so
we tried executing that command we had
an error over there
so what we need to do is we need to
execute this command so dot slash
vmware hyphen install.pl and we'll start
creating now
it will ask you for your input
installing vmware tools in which
directory do you want to install the
binary files uh by default it is going
to
use slash usr slash bin if i just press
enter it is going to use the default as
you can see the input over here
what directory do you want the init
directories i'm just going to press
keep on pressing enter for the defaults
to come in this part does not exist
it is going to create it default yes
defaults
everywhere and then it tries to start
initializing it
to maximize the screen and this is where
it is installing
and you can see by just installing that
it automatically adjusted the screen
and now we got a full screen of kali
linux right here
right and that is what vmware tools does
for us once we have installed
the operating system and now you can see
the entire screen
on here you will see the tool sets that
are given here
now why are we using kali linux in the
first place because this comes in
uh with a bundle of thousands of
softwares that are ready to be utilized
for ethical hacking
right and they have been categorized
over here for information gathering
vulnerability analysis web application
analysis and so on so forth so you can
see from forensics onwards
reporting tools and as you scroll down
you can see your development tools
graphics coming in internet
and the system configuration coming into
the picture these
are your settings for your operating
system so these are basically your tools
we are right now the favorites if i
click on information gathering you will
see that
other tools for information gathering
start appearing over here
for vulnerability analysis we have got
sparta nmap fuzzing tools web
application analysis we have got comics
skip fish
sql map database assessments password
attacks and so on so forth so if we just
go in the favorites
this was the terminal emulator that we
utilized this is the command line that
we saw we used the cd command
we used the pwd command we did the ls
command as well to give us the list
of the directory that we are in
similarly there would be
commands like cat so let's go to cd
downloads let's see what the
uh what's there i can see this case
sensitive so if i type in a capital d
and then do a tab ls there's nothing
over here
on download so cd dot dot will take us
back one directory now you can see we
are back from
downloads to root if i want to go to
desktop
this is how i go to desktop do a ls you
can see the vmware tools
uh folder over there cd vmware tools and
we go into that folder ls which will
give us the list of all those files now
you can see install is a file that we
had
edited back then so if i do a cat
install
you will see the cat basically is the
command that will help us look at the
contents of the file all right without
opening up the file or without editing
the file so you can see just
uh if i scroll up this is where we give
the cat command it then
printed the contents of the file over
here and then it exited and gave me back
to command line right here right now if
i want to copy this
cp root desktop vmware
install and if you want to copy it to
root
downloads and press enter now what we
are going to do is we are going to see
if this file the install file that we
just edited over here
has been copied to the downloads folder
so we do us
we are currently in the vmware on the
desktop vmware tools district folder
video cd dot dot
that takes us down one directory so we
are still in the desktop do a cd dot dot
now you can see we are back in the root
and now we are going to
do a cd downloads run ls and you can see
the
copied file right here so if i do a cat
install
you can see the same content of that
file coming in so these are some of the
commands that we would need to learn as
we go ahead
the remove command is let's say we've
got
install we do a man rm man is the manual
page command
that uh gives us the pages with the
description of how that particular
command is to be utilized so rm is
remove files or directories
synopsis the description the options
hyphen f4 hyphen i for prompt hyphen
capital capitalize prompt once
before removing more than three files
and so on so forth
if you want to exit this you can press q
to exit
and you come back to this page so if i
say rm
install ls you will see that the install
file has now been deleted so in windows
we use the del del command
in linux it is the rm command so this is
what we wanted to look at
the demo for kali linux how to download
it how to install it and some of the
basic commands that we can utilize
all right let's begin with the fishing
uh tutorial
we have the kali linux operating system
booted up over here uh what we are going
to do is we are going to open up a tool
called
set social engineering toolkit which you
would find
in this option and that's the tools that
we want it's a command line tool
a menu driven tool we are going to host
a fake
facebook page and you can see how we can
harvest credentials by this kind of an
attack
so these are some disclaimers you might
want to go through that do you want to
agree to the terms of
service yes press enter
and that's your social engineering
toolkit and we
are talking about a phishing attack
which can comes under the social
engineering attack so it like i said
it's a menu driven tool
so we just have to look at these options
and then just type in the
number of the option that we want so we
want to do a social engineering attack
so i type in one
press enter in that it is asking me
whether i want a spear phishing attack a
website attack vector we are going to
choose a second option so i type in two
press enter
and then it asks me uh what i want to do
i want to take the third option here
credential harvester attack methodology
and we want to do the third attack now
it is asking whether we want
to use the in-house website templates
that it already has or do we want to
clone a site or do we have a customized
site that we have prepared that we want
to migrate into this tool we are going
to do the site cloning option so we are
going to type in two
press enter and then it is going to ask
me the ip address where it wants to
capture
and store the credentials by default
this is the ip address that i'm using so
if i leave it blank
it will take my default ip address so
i'm just going to press enter
and now it is asking me the url to clone
so i type in https www.facebook.com
what it is going to do it is going to
connect online and
it is now just it has cloned the website
uh facebook login.php the best way to
use this attack is that you if you use
the
if the username and password form are in
the same field
or the same page regardless this
captures all posts on a website so
you may need to copy www.star into
html depending on where your directory
structure is press return if you
understand
what we are seeing here so press enter
the social engineering toolkit
credential harvest attack is running on
port 80
information will be displayed to you as
it arrives so the site was 71.134
right the default ip address and this is
where the website is being hosted
let's check that out so let me open up a
browser on my host machine
and let me point it to the kali linux
machine that we have just created
192.168.71.134
and you should see a login to facebook
coming up right here looks
genuine it is genuine because we just
went online and downloaded this let's
just have a recap
let's have a nation of what we are
trying to do i am trying to host
fake facebook page on my server which
has an
embedded script in it which is going to
do credential harvesting
so the attack here is let's say if i'm
now hosted this i can
craft a fake email send it across to a
victim
saying uh your facebook account has seen
some unforeseen activity
create a hyperlink using html coding
within that click here to access your
account and verify
uh that the account is secured and when
they click on that link they will be
redirected to my fake
page which is here you can see the ip
address is my virtual machine's ip
address but i'm seeing a facebook
login page and i'm going to type in
someone at
somewhere.com and the password i'm just
going to type in
the regular ones that i use and if you
see it
when we typed in uh the username and
password the page just refreshed and
gave us the login page again but now if
you look at the url i'm actually on
facebook's login page which is exactly
the same that i was hosting
so a layman wouldn't probably figure out
they've been hacked by now they just
would figure out okay they probably
typed in the incorrect password and the
page refresh or something like that and
they're just going to log
in and they're actually going to access
the facebook page thus
they might not even realize that
something went wrong but if i go back to
my
virtual machine you can see that it has
captured some data and it is reporting
over here
of what has happened so if i just scroll
up let's see what happened here and if
you have been able to
capture anything so we gotta hit
printing the output this does the http
1.1
200 okay response coming in password
field phone
and we just looking there it is
email someone at somewhere.com and
uh password that i typed in asd at the
rate one two three
four so it has captured the username and
the password right here uh
once you're done i mean this is the way
attackers work now this is a very basic
attack
again uh in the actual trainings you
would then look at how you would host
this
on a real website make it a global
attack right now it's a
virtual machine with a class cip address
so
here the thought process is where can we
get a free hosting
where we can host this kind of sites
maybe i'll have to purchase a domain
which looks like similar to facebook or
the victim that i'm trying to attack so
this is just a poc
so we just wanted to find out if we can
uh how phishing is done and this is
exactly how it is done
right so pressing ctrl c would exit this
tool
and takes you back to the actual menu
press 99 99 to exit and
there it is close the two window and
that's
the phishing practical after fishing
let's talk about
sql injection sql injection stands for
uh
structured query language injection
which is a database attack
though it resides within the application
so it's the application vulnerability
that we are trying to
look at to try to bypass authentication
as the name suggests a sequel injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a sql
statement what is a sql statement
a query that is used by an application
and is fired off to the database
database executes that query gets that
information that is required
and sends it back to the user if the
user is authenticated so we're going to
look at the sql injection attack demo
here
and uh what we are going to do is we are
going to go back to our vmware
workstation
and i have got a tool over here called
ovasp broken web application
which is a utility that has been created
for people like us to
test our skills to learn on how we can
develop our skills
further so this has a lot of vulnerable
applications built within it we're just
going to try to access it
and we are going to see if we can create
a sql injection attack
just waiting for it to boot up once it
boots up it will give us an ip address
there we are so we need to connect to
71.132
so i can just use the same browser i was
using
close up facebook and now go to 192 168
71.132 and this is the ovas
broken web application project uh what
we're going to do is we're going to go
to utility
and this is a application that has a lot
of information within it
you can see it gives you links about
what you should do help me
video tutorials listing of
vulnerabilities that they have and so on
so forth so you can see we are not
logged in right now
i'm just going to do this as a demo so
what we're going to do is we're going to
look at this
and bypass authentication so we are
taken to the login page where you need a
username and password to log
in i'm going to type in test as the
username and test as the password
click on login and you can see that
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism works now what
we want to do is we want to create a
query now what does a query look like
when i type in a username and a password
if i just type in a single quote here it
is going to create an error
and this is what the sql query looks
like select username from accounts where
username
is a single quote and then the exception
error happened so it's not showing the
rest of the query to us
now what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to craft a query here
uh single quote and give it a condition
or
one equals one space hyphen hyphen space
what happens hyphen hyphen space is
comments out anything after that so the
password field is being commented out at
this point in time and i'm just giving
it a condition
where the condition is true one does
equal one
and if this condition is true it is
going to allow me to log in so you can
see right now you're not logged in
this bypasses the authentication
mechanism and you can see
user authenticated and we are now logged
in as admin
so uh in the training what we need to
understand uh as a whole
is how sql works what are the queries
that are structured with how you can
what are the testing operators now the
single quote that we used that was an
operator in the sql syntax what these
operators are
how they function and then how we can
leverage these attacks
there are different tools that are given
to you in kali
as well that you can utilize so in kali
linux
you can just open up a command prompt
and there's a tool called sql map
you need to give it a particular site so
sql
map hyphen u for the url and whatever
the url
is now url here and then once you're
here you just
press the enter key this tool will craft
all the queries in the background for
you you don't even have to
no sql query or sql languages uh this
is a very easy tool to utilize sadly i
cannot demo this on a live website
because that would be illegal
but you can see how you can operate this
yourself
that's what uh sequel injections are all
about moving on we now talk about
vpns virtual private networks and a
virtual private network is basically
a secure network that allows me to
anonymize myself over the
internet so what i'm doing is i'm
connecting from here to a server
that encrypts my channel encrypts my
connection and does allows me to
keep my data secure now the basic
essence of a vpn or a virtual private
network
is to allow me this encryption mechanism
where i can
encrypt and safeguard my data the added
advantage that nowadays a vpn gives
is that you can allow us to spoof our ip
address or
obfuscate our ip address so we can
actually become anonymous on the
internet it can allow us to
use multiple ip addresses and thus
secure ourselves on the internet
for example i use vpn called cyber ghost
and what this allows me to do is it
allows me
so many servers over here if you look at
the entire list
all the servers then there are no spy
servers which
and guarantee me that they are not going
to keep and store any
logs and thus they are not going to
record any of the activity that i'm
doing
right since they are located out of
romania this becomes a little bit more
safer for me because the government and
the laws over there are a little bit
more relaxed
than other countries uh they give me
different links for torrenting for
streaming for connection features so
there are a lot of vpns out there so for
example let's
go to the website cyberghost.com so
we can see there's a sale going on 76
percent sale
or you can go on to express vpn
which is also very good vp and then
there is not vpn
it depends on what you want and how you
want to utilize it so
just purchasing a vpn or getting a free
free vpn is not enough
it depends on which country the vpn
originates from and which
server you're connected to for example
most of the
countries have a pact where they share
information amongst themselves even if
you're connected to a vpn that means
that these companies that provide these
services have to generate and store
logs and these logs have to be reported
to the government if they ask for it
now if there's a list of 14 countries
that actually uh
focuses on this practice so you have to
find out vpn that and a server that is
not a part of those 14 countries
and ensure that those logs are not going
to be
reported to the government and these are
three vpns basically are something that
which are good and i personally use
cyberghost i have used the others
i just keep on rotating them just to get
an idea of which one is
better so these are vpns that can allow
you to
anonymize yourself on the internet
moving on
these are the ones that we talked about
there are other safer vpn hide my ass
expressvpn and so on so forth from our
terminologies let's now talk about vps
vps is basically virtual private server
where you can rent a service
or server as a service a virtual machine
as a service so
basically on a cloud using
infrastructure as a service you can rent
a server
and utilize it for whatever activity you
want so let's go to
uh these sites register.com good id
network solutions or we can talk about
other cloud solutions as well
so here you can get register your domain
names
uh so in the previous exercise for let's
say when we talked about
the phishing exercise uh what we want is
we can
go on to register.com or we can go on to
godaddy.com
and we can purchase a particular domain
for example
something like this instead of the o's
i'm typing in a couple of zeros
for the facebook and see let's see if
anything of that is available
now something dot photo is available or
facetips.com is available uh there are
other options that are making aware
that they're giving us over here and
once we purchase this
we can then have our own hosting uh with
our web hosting
as a service and uh you can have a linux
based
uh hosting or a windows-based hosting
depending on what you want and that's
where your shared hosting comes with the
picture
if you just want uh if you want to look
at a virtual server
and you want to render server over there
itself you can move on to rackspace.com
and here in your services you can have
physical server or a virtual server in a
public cloud
your other cloud providers for example
would be amazon aws
and on aws you can basically look at ec2
elastic compute cloud which is basically
virtual servers in the cloud
and over here you can rent out a server
with whatever capacity you require
you'll obviously have to pay rent for
what those servers are going to cost
but once you have those servers you can
then launch any services
on top of it looking at other services
that we have
we talked about tor tor is a onion
routing
software that allows users to browse the
web anonymously so we can just go online
and we can try to spoof our identity and
i'm going to show you how
so i've got a vmware workstation right
here the one so we're just going to pull
that up and we're going to power on a
windows 7 machine
where we're going to look at the onion
routing so windows machine has booted up
we're just going to log
in and this is my windows 7 machine now
i've got a
chrome browser right here and we're
going to go to a website called
cmyip.com which is going to give
the ip address that i'm currently using
so right now i'm not on connected to any
vpn or anything and you can see that's
my ip address that i'm utilizing
now if i want to anonymize myself what
i'm going to do is
i am going to use star and that's the
tor browser that's set up right there if
i click on it it's going to open up
the software and it's going to create a
new network and it's going to connect to
the tor network and allow me to
anonymize myself
right so that's the top browser opening
up and
giving me a new browser over here so
i've got one
which is the old one which is my current
ip address if i just refresh that
you'll see that i'm still on the same ip
address as far as this browser is
concerned
there's a refresh and it's still showing
me the same ip address where if i go on
to thor right now and if i go to see
my ip.com you will see that it is going
to give me
and you can see the amount of time it is
taking to reach that site that's because
i
am using a vpn and there's a lot of
encryption
running off and you can see now i'm
certainly connected
via hong kong and even to reach this
site what tor does is it gives me
a proxy chain a proxy chain is where it
creates multiple hops to hide my
identity and
before i reach see my ip.com i am using
three different ip addresses over here
one in france one
in germany and one in hong kong so if i
do something over here
to trace back my steps to my actual ip
address the law enforcement agencies or
anyone who is going to
search like a forensic investigator
would have to go through these ip
addresses before they come back to me
now it's not impossible but the effort
and time that's going to be taken to
come across three different countries
is going to be phenomenal so it may just
defeat the purpose
of having so much resources spent to
identify who did what so that's what
thought does
for us all right moving on from tor we
are going to look at keyloggers
keyloggers are basically softwares that
run in the background
and record all the keystrokes of the
user so if i've got a keylogger
installed right now
whatever i type will be stored in a text
file for the hacker
so that they can look at it later on and
just to give you an example of that we
go back to my vmware workstation and we
open up another windows 7 machine
i'm going to power this on and i'm going
to close this one to them
so this virtual machine has booted up we
are going to use
user one login as user one just close
all these softwares uh which are not
required
and once this machine is booted up what
we're going to do is i'm just going to
open up a random
websites and see what we're doing
basically there's a keylogger that's
there in the
startup that's going to record our
keystrokes
and we just want to see what it actually
does now firefox is getting updated
so let's hold on now this is the latest
version of firefox right
and we're just going to go to let's say
facebook.com
wait for the website to open up all
right let's try opening it up again
and that's facebook.com and we're just
going to type in some random username
and password
somewhere someone at somewhere.com and
the password being again
asd rate one two three four five six
seven eight
nine zero log in obviously that login is
not going to work user probably doesn't
exist
or if it does the password probably is
correct incorrect and
uh so we're going to close this
we're going to let's say open up another
browser window go to another site
and then go to red if mail try the same
thing over here
someone at somewhere.com
password is d31234567 whatever it is
don't say we can see the combination is
incorrect now there's a keylogger
running in the background and what we
want is we now want to
open up the keylogger now it is visible
here because i've kept it visible
you can hide it in the start menu and
there's a shortcut key for you to pull
it up later on
so this completely becomes invisible and
what it can do is it basically creates a
record of whatever
you have been doing so far so you can
see these things populating on the 25th
of december so if i look at the visited
website you can see i
opened up mozilla firefox the first
where it uh there was a problem loading
the page then we opened up facebook
then we opened up reliefmail.com and so
on and so forth said this
it just gives me the list of visited
websites whereas
if i look at keystrokes and clipboard
you will see whatever we have typed in
so we first typed in facebook.com then
again uh the second time i
try try to type in then i hit backspace
then i type in facebook.com and then
you can see i typed in someone at
somewhere.com and then tab
asd at the rate one two three four five
six seven eight nine zero we closed up
the browser we opened up a new one
and we went on to rediffmail.com and
then you can see
me typing this one then going back one
space then the rest of what i typed and
then the
password coming in so that's what a
keylogger does if you look at the
taskbar it's not going to show you a
keylogger running in the background it's
in processes you're not going to see
anything at all
but it's going to mask itself as a
service so if you look into the
properties you can see that icon coming
in over here
which matches this one and so you can
see that this masking itself as a
service dot exe
if this gets hidden as well it would be
very
difficult for a user to even identify
this all right so that's what a key
logger is
moving on let's see what else we want to
talk about so we've talked about
tar we have talked about key loggers and
now we want to talk about firewalls now
for keyloggers to be prevented we need
antiviruses right so we
need a good antivirus program that's
going to be installed updated
and run on a regular basis to protect
ourselves from malware
but what about network connections and
you need a firewall and a system
to prevent or to detect what kind of
connections are going on in the first
place
now we cannot rely on software's 100
percent so even if a firewall is not
configured properly
that's that's going to be a problem so
what we need to do is we have to have a
firewall
configure it correctly and then allow
and disallow certain
activity from of uh happening and what
we're going to do is
i've got such a system on my machine
here i use a software called glasswire
what it does is it is a network analyzer
so it allows me to analyze whatever is
going on you can see all the apps that
i'm utilizing and how much
upload and download they have been doing
all the traffic so you can see the
protocols that i'm utilizing so i come
to know what's going on in the
background
and this gives me the entire graph of
how much i have been doing for the past
24 hours past three hours
past five minutes and so on so forth
right so this is what the activities and
these are the alerts that it has been
generating
i can click on those alert and it will
start telling me what it was all about
if the graph doesn't work for me it
gives me usage as well
so how much i have utilized since i've
installed this software
right and what applications have been
utilized which hosts i've been connected
to and the traffic type that was
utilized
and then the things on my network so
these are the devices that i have
currently on my network that has been
that have been identified and then comes
the firewall so on the firewall
the firewall is clicked on you see all
those services that have been identified
and you can just click on a particular
service to lock that service
so this becomes a discovery tool
identifies whatever networking is going
on
gives me all that information and then i
can look at and i can just click on any
of these
services that i find it as malicious and
block them
i can create different profiles for
different applications as
and and these are the alerts so you can
see that this was the first time a
network connection
was looked at from vmware and what this
allows me to do is whenever i execute a
file it can upload it to virustotal.com
and scan it as a
third party antivirus to ensure that
there is nothing malicious on it so i
already have an antivirus over here but
if this ever gets compromised i still
can rely on a third party service
where in real time as an and when i
execute my applications uh
they would be verified and i would be
assured that nothing is wrong with my
system
and this software that i'm utilizing
glass wire basic
is free and then there are paid versions
as well it's just glasswire.com is where
you're going to find this
moving on rootkit rootkits are also
malicious softwares that you allow
an unauthorized user to have access to a
computer to restrict areas of its
software
now a root kitten is a census which a
software a malicious software that
infects a machine
and prevents a from some functionality
from it like hiding data or
preventing users from running
antiviruses and
it's basically a malicious software that
is used to hide information from the
victims so that they would not realize
that they have actually been compromised
it's going to be a
difficult showing of a root kit so i
cannot show that demo to you so we're
just going to move on
and we are going to talk about ethical
hacking techniques now now when we say
ethical hacking techniques we want to
look at what kind of audits are
available when we want to do ethical
hacking so
there's a black box audit a white box
audit and a gray box audit so if i'm
invited in an organization
to conduct a test to conduct a audit
to conduct a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test to
identify vulnerabilities and then try to
plug them out
they are going to give me three
different variations in a black box
audit they are not going to tell me
about the infrastructure they are not
going to give me any information
and they want me to start from the
basics of gathering information
identifying their systems and
based on the information that i gather
whether i'm able to develop
any hacks and compromise their
infrastructure so it will be a
simulation of a hacker who's sitting
outside the organization
and trying to find a way in whereas a
white box audit is where full
infrastructure knowledge is given
anything and everything that is required
for an audit is given
and this is a simulation of an insider
attack a person sitting inside the
organization misusing
their permissions and then trying to
compromise trying to get access to data
that they do not have access to
so the simulation is from a malicious
insider a gray box is where some partial
knowledge is available
and from that partial knowledge you're
going to try to build up more
information and then you're going to try
to get
access to those resources what are the
tools that we utilize
so we've already had a couple of demos
on keyloggers
sql injection sql map and so on so forth
metasploit is a very much used tool for
penetration testing
and uh having knowledge on metasploit is
very much necessary as far as ethical
hacking
is concerned nmap this is a tool used
for network discovery
necessarily scanner wireshark is a
packet capturer that allows you to
capture packets
and analyze whatever is going on sql map
is something that we have seen a sequel
injection attack tool
which generates its own queries and john
the ripper is a password cracking tool
uh backtrack used to be an operating
system that was utilized
for penetration testing however
backtrack has now been replaced by
something called kali linux and that's
the operating system that we have
utilized in all our demos
where we tried to look at sql map and
those injection attacks that we did
so what are the areas of ethical hacking
we have just talked about
all these areas as well network services
we looked at the glasswire
application that showed us how my
machine is consuming networks which
protocols are being
consumed how the connections are being
uh created
if somebody's able to install a trojan
on my machine it is going to try to
create a new
connection on the network with the
hacker to allow that hacker a backdoor
access
now if i have that glass wire or a
similar
firewall implemented it is this wire
wall that is going to detect it
and prevent that connection from
happening so if i install a software
that is certainly suspicious or that
install something else in the background
that i may not be aware of
that tool is going to identify all the
connections that are being made and it
is going to highlight that connection
i need to go through all of those
connections and identify whether they
are legit
or not and if i find some suspicious or
doubtful
i'm going to block that connection and
then i'm going to investigate what's
going on
and that's where ethical hacking comes
into the picture you want to find out if
your firewall
that you have implemented is going to
work correctly or not if the
configuration of the firewall is done
properly
or if the firewall is misconfigured is
it leaking out information
right at the same time you're looking at
web applications we looked at the ovas
broken web application where we did some
sql injection attacks
right so that was a weakness or a
vulnerability in that application
which would allow us to bypass
authentication and get access
to resources that we were not authorized
for and then client-side attack should
be where
you install keylogger at the end of the
at the client system
and then you try to capture whatever
data the user is typing in
like usernames and passwords on the
facebook and the rediff mail.com website
that we saw
and then try to misuse that information
to get access to those resources
then wi-fi networks right wi-fi is
something that we use on a regular basis
we got our smart devices nowadays
smartphones tablets phablets
that we can connect to wi-fi and start
using all our services our banking
applications and our smartphones and
thus we want to ensure that wireless
connectivity is simple and is secured
so you want to use encryption mechanisms
you want to use tools on your
smartphones anti-viruses firewalls on
your smartphones to ensure that
whatever you are utilizing is going to
remain secure and then social
engineering we've looked at the phishing
website on facebook.com we've seen how
easy it is to clone websites
and host them on apache server
so if you look at it from ethical
hackers perspective the job of ethical
hacker is to simulate these kind of
attacks
that the hacker may conduct and first of
all you basically going to find out
areas where these attacks can happen
think of it from a hacker's perspective
try to simulate those attacks and see if
those attacks are going to be effective
can those attacks be prevented and can
your current security controls that you
have
put in place identify detect and prevent
these attacks from happening in the
first place
and that is what ethical hacking is all
about let's look at the metasploit
attack metasploit is a framework of
penetration testing that makes hacking
very simple you just need to know how to
utilize the tool you need to identify
the vulnerability associated with the
particular
exploit and then run the exploit on
metasploit
we'll be demoing this during the
practical so there are active exploits
and passive exploits
inactive exploits exploits a specific
computer runs until execution and then
exits
uses brute force and exits when an error
occurs
in a passive exploit these exploits wait
for incoming requests
and exploit them as soon as they connect
they can also be used in conjunction
with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we
like a reverse connection payload we
send it to the victim
once the victim installs that software
the machine will then initiate a
connection to us
our machine will be in a listen mode and
then we will
once the software is executed at there
and we would then try to connect and
exploit that particular vulnerability
this is the
practical that we'll be doing on
metasploit so let's move on with the
demos
and then we'll see what we can discuss
amongst them
all right let's have a look at some of
the demos that we had uh talked about in
the ethical hacking and penetration
testing module
we are going to look at three different
demos the first one is going to be a sql
injection attack that we are going to
perform on
this tool that we have the second one is
a password cracking attack on windows 7
and the third one is a meter breeder
based or a metasploit based
shell shock attack on a linux based web
server so let's get cracking
i've powered on this virtual machine
which is the ovas broken web application
it is a tool that is provided for people
who want to enhance their skills and
they can practice
how to do these attacks in a legal
manner
so we are going to go to this site i'm
just going to open up my browser the ip
address is 71.132
and that's the ovas broken web
application that we want to utilize
we're going to head off to mutilate a2
and we
are going to look at a sql injection
attack where we want to bypass
authentication now this takes us to the
login screen
so we can just try our luck here and see
that the authentication mechanism works
the account does not exist so the good
that we have supplied
is not the correct one so we want to
ensure that there's a sequel database
and we can try to attack it and see
if we can bypass the authentication now
uh what we want to do is we want to
create a sequel based malformed query
that can give us a different output i'm
just going to type in a single quote
over here
and type login and you can see that this
is now suddenly recognized
as a operator and there's an error that
is given out
compared to the login that we tried uh
earlier when we used a proper
text-based login mechanism it gave us
the account does not exist but here the
signal code gave
us a error and it shows us how sql works
this is the query that we had created
now in the trainings that you have
for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what this queries are
all about how the syntax works
here we're just going to see if we can
create a malform query to
log in as a user in this case so what
i'm going to do is
uh create the query with a comparison so
we're going to give it
r one equals one space hyphen knife
space and if you now click login you
should be able to bypass authentication
and you can see user
has been authenticated and we now have
admin access to this application
now here the sql queries need to be
crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is
there's a microsoft database an oracle
database and so on so forth and then you
have to choose those proper commands
but identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
the
format are they stored and what this
tool does to retrieve those
that's something that we all need to
know as ethical hacker
right so import the hashes from local
system
click on next it's going to enumerate
that file and it is going to give you a
list of all the users
that are there so you can see the users
or hacker admin
test the one that we are logged in as
and then the user called
virus as well and you can see that this
is the what characters are being
utilized over here so we just
create an attack like this using
all characters and uh lowercase a
through z
uppercase a through z numeric zero
through nine and all the special
characters
let's say that password is between seven
and sixteen characters
and this is the character set that we
want to try the brute force attack on
what is a brute force attack it is an
attack where
the computer is going to try each and
every permutation and combination
out of this character set and try to
figure out if the password is going to
be correct
so if we click start it's going to start
with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character
and you can see the time is going to be
phenomenal over here
so it's not necessary that this attack
would be viable
it will be 100 successful given the time
frame however
the time frame is huge enough for this
attack to become a little bit redundant
there are other attacks that we can do
which can easily
identify this data for us as well but
that is something that we will look on
in future videos so that's how we can
get access to users and passwords
there are different mechanisms where
let's say we don't have login access
then what are we going to do how we can
create a fake user login or how we can
remotely access a machine
and then try to get the same access and
that is what we are going to try to do
in the next
demo on a linux machine so what we are
doing in a linux machine could also be
doable on the windows machine with a
different exploit so what i'm going to
do is
this is the linux web server that i have
that i'm going to power on
i'm going to use a kali linux machine to
hack that
device and i'm going to just power off
my windows 7 machine give it a minute
till it boots up
now this is also a demo machine that we
have which has
its own pre-configured vulnerabilities
so here
we've got something from the pentester's
lab and has a shell shock vulnerability
implemented inside shell shock
vulnerability affects
linux mac and unix-based operating
systems for a particular version of the
bash
shell bash is the bone again shell which
is the command is
and my appearance is this with a subnet
mask of two five five two five five two
five five dot zero so i want to see if
there are any other machines that are
live
in the same subnet and we are doing a
pink sweep over here to identify which
machines are live
in a minute we'll get all the ip
addresses 71.1
to 133 254 and 128. we know that we are
128 at this point in time
uh 254 is the dhcp server so we are
assuming that 133
is the machine that we want to look at
and let's then
try to see if we can scan that machine
133 and we're going to do an intense
scan
to find out which ports are open what
services are running over there and if
it is whether the pentest machine that
we were looking for
you can see of the start port 22 and
port 80
and somewhere here it's going to give us
the
ports that are open and the details
about those ports and somewhere here it
will tell us that this is the pentester
lab machine that we wanted
which is correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this
what we're going to do is i'm going to
use another gui based tool called sparta
which i can just find out from here
sparta uses two tools in the background
a nmap tool and a tool called nikto
so we're just going to start scanning
192 168
71.133 was the ip address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information
there we are that's the nikto tool
coming in scanning on port 80 which is
uh which means that it's a web server
using http
it tells us it's an apache http 2.2.21
and gives us the 22 port number as well
if we head over to the tab
of nicto or let's look at the screenshot
first this is what the website would be
looking like
and nicto gives us the options over here
it tells us that
there is a vulnerability over here for
shell shock and this is the path where
the vulnerability is going to exist
so what we are going to do we go back to
the command line sorry we open up a new
one
minimize all these other windows and we
are going to open up
metasploit metasploit is a penetration
testing tool that is used by most
hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications
and test existing exploits and
vulnerabilities so just give it a minute
till it starts
you can see there are already around
1700 exploits right here
we're going to see all those exploits
with these commands
there we are sorry for the typo and it
will just give us a list of
all the exploits that are stored in
metasploit in this version
so all of these are windows based if we
scroll up we will be looking at other
vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the unique space exploits
linux osx
multi-exploits and we're looking for a
exploit
for um multi-based apache
or http let's go up let's
look at so this is the one that we are
looking for apache
mod cgi bash environmental executable so
what we're going to do is we're just
going to copy it
go back to the bottom say use exploit
and paste the one that we wanted press
enter
say show options so it'll ask us to
configure this i'm just going to
configure it based on
the knowledge that we have set our host
which is the remote host
the victims machine so we put in the ip
address
it asks us for the target uri so that's
the path that we saw
set target uri to
cgi hyphen bill slash status
enter now with exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want
so we say show payloads and it will give
us a list of all the compatible payloads
with this exploit
and we want to create a reverse tcp
connection which is this so we know it's
a linux operating system we want this
payload to be set so set payload
press enter that's the payload coming in
show options
now that we have set the payload this is
the options for the exploit and now we
want to
set our options for the payloads as well
so we are creating a reverse tcp
connection which means we are remotely
executing code at the victim side
and making the victim connect back to
our machine which means we need to set
up a listener
so i need to put my ip address over here
set localhost or lhost
192.168.71.128 which was our ip address
show options again just to ensure
everything is fine which looks like it
is and we then type in the word exploit
so that it will start this attack
you can see that it has created a meter
builder session at the victim site
and it has opened up a session so if i
do a pwd
now pwd is a linux command for present
working directory and it will show us
that we'll
connect it to where cgi hyphen bin
do an ls it will list all the files
that's the status file over there
do a cd backslash it will take us to the
root of this
machine now remember we saw the
passwords on a windows machine
similarly we can head over to the cd etc
folder
ls and you can see these files psswd
and shadow now psswd is the file where
linux stores its usernames and shadow is
the file where passwords are shown so do
a cat command
psswd and you can see these users coming
up so you can see the last user pen test
lab
and you can see there are no passwords
so let's do a cat
shadow and that's your hash value for
the password that we have
for the user print test lab so these are
the different attacks that we need to
understand
and we need to create based on the
vulnerabilities that exist
on different machines so we just looked
at windows and linux and how we can
exploit them
depending on existing vulnerabilities as
an ethical hacker this is
uh what we need to learn in our
trainings
and then we need to clear our exams
based on this knowledge of how these
things
work so that we get certified and then
we can
position ourselves for the penetration
testing jobs
so let's begin with what is sql
injection
as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability allows an attacker to
inject malicious input into a
sql statement so sql stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database
now normally this attack is targeted
towards a database to extract
the data that is stored within however
the vulnerability does not lie in the
database itself
the vulnerability will always lie in the
application
it is the developer's prerogative of how
to develop the application how to
configure it
to prevent sql injection queries from
happening
a database is created to answer
questions and if a question is asked
it is supposed to answer it database
needs to be configured
for some amount of security but the
vulnerability the flaw here for sql
injection
will always lie in the application
itself it does how the application
interacts
with the database that needs to be
modified that needs to be maintained by
the developer
rather than just configuring the
database itself so
the attacker at this point in time when
they send a query to the application
will form a malformed query by injecting
a particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the sql language
and if that operator is passed through
the application to the database
then the database basically gets cracked
or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in
so this character needs to be filtered
at the application level itself
now let's look at a quick demo so what
we have done here is
i have this virtual machine called ovasp
broken web applications virtual machine
version 1.2
i'm going to power this on
till this power is on i'm going to show
you where we can download this
uh utility from so you can just
look for wasp broken web application
project download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net
click on the link you can download the
broken web application project from here
this is a 1.9 gb download
and you can have a zip machine directly
for vmware or
every oracle virtual box now
this is an application that has been
developed by ovas which stands for open
web application security project
which is a not-for-profit organization
and uh
periodically releases the most top 10
risks
that an application will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application
with inbuilt vulnerabilities for
professionals like us to practice upon
to develop
our skills upon because doing this in
the real world
is illegal i cannot go on to a website
to demonstrate how a sequel injection
attack works
neither should you try your hands on it
till you become very
well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine host it in
a vmware workstation
or an oracle virtual box and you can
then try your skills on it
right so just going back to the browser
here if i open up
a new tab you'll see that this machine
has booted up and has an ip address
called 71.132
so if i just go on to that ip address
and i type in 192 168
71.132 and you'll see the os
broken web application project and there
are a lot of training applications
realistic intentionally vulnerable
applications old versions of real
applications and so on so forth
so there is a lot of applications in
built over here that you can
try your skills upon we are going to try
to use the ovas
mutility over here this gives you the
uh os top 10 risks for 2010 2013
2017 is the latest one so far uh but
the difference between 2013 and 2017 is
that some of these have changed but not
all of them
the order has changed a little bit but
you can see that sql injection is
on the top a1 amongst the injection
attacks
right and you can see there are multiple
types that have been given here the
sequel injection for extracting data
or sql injection for bypass
authentication or insert your injection
uh attacks blind sql injection and then
there is a tool called sql map
which is available freely on your linux
machines kali linux or parrot linux
whichever you want to use
uh for your practice targets and so on
and so forth so
if i just take you here for bypass
authentication
and this is a regular login page that an
application may have
right you look at a username you like a
password you type that in
and you log in so let's say i don't know
a
password here i'm just going to type in
the username test password is psswrd
i try to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does
work uh i did try typing a username and
password it wasn't recognized so the
account does not exist
now let's try to type in a sql query
here i'm going to just give it a single
quote which is an
operator that is recognized by the sql
language which when
the database tries to execute uh will
cause the database to uh dump some data
or to bypass authentication in this case
and i'm going to give it a condition
single quote or
one equals one space hyphen iphone space
and i'm going to click on login now
right now i'm not logged in at all and
we tried our username and password and
we weren't able to log in so now if i
log in
you will see that it give me a status
update saying the user has been
authenticated
and i'm logged in as admin got root so
that is what this is is it is where we
combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
url earlier in the url
you would see a large structure in that
url
uh we can try to add more two or more
statements within the url itself
to combine them and then confuse the
database into executing giving a data
dump
at the same time right so what would an
error-based
sql injection look like if i go back to
the same database
uh which is here right and if you
remember the username we gave
it a single quote or one equals one
space hyphen knife and space
we gave it the condition right so
basically what it did was
a single quote is an operator that goes
to the database selects
the default uh table in the user tables
in this database column
and then compares it to the condition
that is given so the condition that we
gave our hacker of how they want to
proceed next what kind of queries they
want to create
what kind of syntax they want to youtube
so error-based
attack is where you generate these kind
of errors and you get this information
the union base is where you craft your
queries within the url
uh you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
then we come to boolean based sql
injection
uh sends a sql query to the database
which forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a
false result so basically if
the input is false the input both the
inputs are false the output would be
false
uh there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input b
the output would be true and so on so
forth right so depending on the result
from the inputs that i
will come to know which input is true
with this he can then access the
database of the website so you're trying
to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
which command exactly work what was the
resultant
output of that command thus from this
kind of an information the hacker can
infer
their next step forward then you have
time-based sql injections
uh now there are times when a database
administrator or an application
administrator has done some security
configuration
and does have disabled verbose error
messages
now what is a verbose error message the
error message that we saw right here is
a verbose error message that means
that the message gives out details the
message gives out details about
what the database is the version and
whatnot so if
they have sanitized these errors and
you no longer can generate these errors
and thus you cannot figure out
what database is then what do you do
right
for example if i just take you to simply
learn
and
take you to a url that is supposedly not
accessible
you can see that that gives a generic
error oops like
it looks like you have crash landed on
mars it doesn't give you a
verbose error that is a detail error of
what went wrong where
it gives us the database the version of
the database and
uh the query went wrong and etc etc etc
whereas on this side where there's some
there's a lot of security that goes in
here so you can see that
it doesn't generate a error let's get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do
so the hacker then injects a time based
uh query in the url which allows us
to verify whether the command is being
executed or not so
uh we put in a time weight let's say 10
seconds of time wait so if we
the moment we inject the query if the
query
times for 10 seconds and then gets
executed that means that
the sql injection is possible however
if we inject the query and uh it just
gets executed without the delay
that means that the time uh injection
attack would not be
uh possible on that particular site out
of bound is not a very common attack it
depends on the features being the
enabled on the database management
system that has been used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error
by the database administrator where you
have enabled functions
and not sanitize them so you have not
done in
access controls properly you have not
given account control so
queries should never be executed at an
administrative level
they should always be uh executed at a
user level
with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions
to be to be enabled at the dbms and
there is an administrative account that
can have access to them
at that point in time and out of bound
injection attack is possible
so let's look at how a website works
right
uh how sequel works on a website now the
website is constructed of html
hypertext markup language uh which would
include javascripting for functionality
cascading style sheet
for the mapping of the website right and
then
js and whatnot for further functionality
now when we send a query to the website
it is normally
using the http protocol or https
protocol
when the query reaches the application
the application would then go ahead and
generate the
sql query uh at the client side you'll
have
all these scripting languages coming in
on the front end
that we can utilize to craft queries and
then send them across
at the server side you will have uh
databases like oracle mysql ms sql and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries
right so just to give you an example
if i use a tool called postman
what we generally do when we craft a
query is we send out a
get request to the website
and then we receive a response from the
site with the html code and everything
so this is a tool that is utilized by
software testers to
test the responses that you're going to
get from various websites
so on the left hand side you can see
i've used it on quite a bit
uh here we have an example for gmail.com
so let's continue with
that so this is a get request being sent
to gmail the moment i send it it's going
to create an http request
and send it across the response that i
get is this this is the html code for
gmail.com
right these are the cookies uh these are
the headers
uh that include information so you can
see this is a text html
character set utilizes utf-8 and the
configuration
uh that has been done with the
application right so this is where
uh everything comes in this is the
cookie that has been sent with that
particular
uh request that i had sent out now if
you analyze
this query right so when we went on to
this application and i typed in that
single quote and we generated this error
right uh you can see that the
application converted this
into a sql query so the query was select
username from accounts where the
username
in quote single quotes and we use this
quote right
the single quote right there so
uh that's where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred
so these are the kind of queries that
are structured by the application
and then taken on to the database for
execution when we type in
uh it is a http get request with the
username and password within that query
uh that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a
sql query sends it to the database and
the database responds with the
appropriate
response so how do we prevent sql
injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterize
queries
these statements make sure that the
parameters pass into sql statements are
treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
quote was an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place
right so here what we are doing here is
a secure way of running a sql query in
the jdbc using a parameterized statement
define which user we want to find so
there's a string the email comes in
connection to the database we are going
to figure out how the connection is
going to be passed how it is going to be
created
construct the sql statement we want to
run specifying the parameter right
so we define how is it going to be uh
created what is going to be created what
can be passed to the database and what
should not be passed to the database
so that is one way of utilizing prepared
statements and parameterized queries
then we have object relational mapping
most development
uh teams prefer to use objection object
relational mapping frameworks to make
the translation of sql results
set into code objects more seamless so
this is an example
of object relational mapping uh where we
map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed
and then escaping inputs in a simple way
to protect against most sql injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions
to achieve this right so you need to be
very careful while using escape
characters in your code base when a sql
statement is constructed
not all injection attacks rely on abuse
of code characters
so you need to know what characters are
being utilized
in the configuration that you have
created in the structure that you have
created in the code that you have
created
which characters are being recognized as
operators
you need to sanitize those operators and
you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input
if they are they're faded out by the
application and they never reach the
database other methods of preventing sql
injection
are password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use
or some other service for a single
sign-on mechanism
does you rely on a third party
to maintain the security of
authentication and
uh what kind of parameters are passed
for example
uh using linkedin logins or facebook
logins right
uh for the layman you normally go on to
facebook and you allow
if you're using a game right if you
start playing a game you're allowed to
log into the game using your facebook
credentials
or your google credentials now that is
not just for ease of use
but the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as facebook or
google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be
facebook and google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of security
experts
and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is top notch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third-party authentication
mechanism to ensure that
these kind of attacks may not happen
then web application
firewalls uh having a web application
firewall and configuring it properly
for sql injection attacks is one of the
sure shot method
of uh mitigating or minimizing the
threat in the first place so at this
point in time you have realized that the
application has some vulnerabilities for
sql injection
and instead of recording or
restructuring the application
uh you want to take the easier way out
or the cheaper way out
so what you do is you you install it
may be completely insecure tomorrow or
the day after
right so you need to keep on upgrading
the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the vulnerability still exists
you might want to migrate to a better
software and thus
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them
to uh enhance your security postures
and then continuously monitor sql
statements and databases use protocol
monitors
use different softwares use the
firewalls to keep on monitoring what
kind of queries you're
getting and based on those queries you
want to ensure
the inputs and the queries that are
creating
are not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have
so let's start looking at the
certifications ethical hacker you must
hold a certification which specializes
in
ethical hacking or in cyber security
please look for candidates who are
globally certified
when we say globally certified they're
looking for a
certificate that has been given by an
organization that is recognized globally
and is well accepted in the industry so
these are the top
five certifications our candidate can
obtain the first one
become a certified ethical hacker then
there is global information assurance
certification penetration tester
then offensive security certified
professional comptria pentest plus
and finally the license penetration
tester now these certifications
are offered by different organizations
all of these organizations are
recognized
globally and their certifications are
well accepted
in the technical space so let's start
off with the certified ethical hacker
and we'll look at
the organizations that provide these
certifications and how we can attain
them
ceh or certified ethical hacker in its
current form is in its version 10 it's
been revised
and a period of time ec council is the
certifying authority for ceh
they have their own authorized training
centers through which you can attend
trainings
give those exams get yourself certified
and thus become globally certified
and can be eligible to apply for
security related jobs
it is a very well known certification
and is widely accepted at the same time
it would test the candidates knowledge
of security threats and preventive
measures now there are two types of
exams that you can give with ceh
one is a multiple choice question exam
which is theoretical in nature
they ask you questions and you answer
the correct uh you'd select the correct
answers
if you're clear you get certified the
second certification
nowadays is where there's a practical
exam associated with it that's a
you'll have to purchase the voucher for
that exam and give that exam
the practical exam is held in a virtual
lab where they
you're given scenarios and based on
those scenarios you have to
resolve the questions given to you and
give
proof of the resolution which would then
get you certified as an ethical hacker
the theoretical exam
in this scenario is the fees this is for
the multiple choice question exam
where you can pay the fees and you can
attend through
a online portal and you can give the
exam directly
the exam is four hours long in which you
have to answer 125 questions
now four hours for 125 questions seems a
long time
technical exam there are scenarios
questions and it would take
some time for you to analyze and
understand the question and then
identify the equivalent correct answer
so it's a very competitive exam and
you'll have to study really hard to
clear this exam as well
the cutoff for passing varies from 60 to
85 percent so there is no
exact grade and all the questions have
different weightages
so depending on the questions that have
been given to you and the way that you
have answered them
you would pass at either 60 or you would
pass when you scored 85 percent
once you are ceh certified which is a
very technical certification
you will be qualified to apply for job
roles as a penetration tester or a
security engineer
these are job roles where you would be
responsible of
ethically trying to attack applications
servers switches and try to find out
vulnerabilities within them
the training of this certification will
make you adept in most of these tools
that are required
there are a lot of practicals in this
training and
if you successfully completed those
practicals clearing the exam
is a easy task with the practicals comes
your knowledge and would help you
understand
how you would be performing penetration
tests in the real world
an average annual salary in the usa for
a cea certified person is around 91 000
and in india is around 4 like 76 000 odd
rupees
the salaries would vary as far as
organizations are concerned
more established organizations can
afford to pay a little bit more
but these are average raw salaries that
we have seen across the market the next
certification
is the gpen also known as the global
information assurance certification
penetration tester
this certification looks into the
different pen testing practices and
methods
also focuses on the various problems and
pen testing
so again this is where you getting
certified as a penetration tester
so it's again a technical certification
where your knowledge on networking
applications and security of which will
be tested
you will be trained on this of course so
the training will include
all these areas where you need to focus
identify those problems
and thus be ready for the real world
scenarios
the candidate will have to understand
networking concepts
and operating systems such as linux and
windows and you should be very well
aware of the tcp protocols
this is true for any of the technical
certifications for ethical hacking
giac is the certification provider it's
again a very well renowned and well
accepted
certification authority across the globe
the exam fees
are 1899 82 215 questions to be answered
in three hours
now why 82 215 it depends on the test
that has been associated
and depending on how you are answering
those questions uh you
would be given those many number of
questions to begin with but all of these
need to be answered in three hours
74 is the past percentage that is
required to clear this exam
the average annual salary in the usa is
around 96
000 while in india it is around
similar to certified ethical hacking
then looking at the next certification
from offensive security called the oscp
offensive security certified
professional this is another penetration
testing
certification highly technical in nature
and it is an entirely hands-on
certification the previous
two certifications that we saw we talked
about ceh where there are two different
exams you could either
take the theoretical exam and give your
mcqs or you could take the practical one
here you don't have an option this is a
practical exam
so the test is conducted on a virtual
network so they send out
instructions to you there's a virtual
lab that is given out to you
and they give you the questions and you
have to perform those assessments
create those reports and provide it to
the certifying authority
in this case offensive security uh if
you match their criterias of whatever
you have identified in those reports you
get certified
here the requirements of good
understanding of networking protocols
how systems function how kali linux
operating system functions
and the candidate must complete
offensive securities penetration testing
with the kali linux course
and pass the hands-on exam so this
focuses purely on kali linux
kali linux is an operating system that
is freely distributed over the internet
and comes structured with around 300
plus tools
used for ethical hacking so this course
totally relies on kali linux for you to
use as a tool set for penetration
testing the certificate provider as
stated
is offensive security the name of the
course is oscp
offensive security certified
professional exam is around 800
to 1550. now understand that this
exam is technical and is hands-on
so for you to prepare for this exam they
come up with virtual labs where you can
start practicing
and honing your skills depending on the
number of days
for which you have purchased the access
to that particular labs the amount will
vary from 800
which would be the minimum access days
available to 1550
where the maximum number of days would
be given to you for practicing
once you are ready even during the time
spa time span of where you have that
access
once you are ready for the exam you can
you can attempt the exam and clear the
average annual salary
is similar around 91 000 dollars for the
us market
and 905 000 rupees in the indian
market then looking at the comptia
pentest plus
comptia is another certification
authority or a certification provider
a training provider that that will help
you get yourself certified in the
ethical hacking space
so they have certification called pen
test plus which is
focused towards penetration testing so
it is an intermediate level
certification it assesses the
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing skills
of a candidate here the training will
provide you with all the essentials
where it will help you identify how to
do vulnerability assessments how to
identify those vulnerabilities
and then which tools to utilize for what
kind of a penetration test
for the requirements a minimum of three
to four years of hands-on experience in
the information security field
also a comptia security plus or a
network plus
or equivalent knowledge is required so
in the network plus
uh they talk about securing networks and
they help you understand the osi layers
the tcp layers
and help you understand the protocols
and all of those things
so having that knowledge isn't an added
advantage the certificate provider is
comptia
and the cost of the exam is around 349
maximum number of questions is 85
and i think it's a three hour
the passing percentage is uh scoring 750
marks
out of a possible 900. so the scale is
the minimum
you can have a score is 100 if you're
completely unprepared the maximum you
can score
is 900 uh you get a leeway of 150 marks
for your
certifications so you have to score a
minimum of 750 to clear the exam
average annual salary for your hampshire
certified penetration test
plus professional is ninety seven
thousand dollars in the us market
and in the indian market it would be
around five lakh rupees
then comes the license penetration
tester now this is an advanced
certificate again from ec
council this is where ac council gives
you a license
which certifies that you have undergone
thorough training
and have cleared your exam in which you
can
conduct or lead a audit for
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing
it is an expert level certification
comes after the ceh certification
it is the ultimate test which tests this
candidate's penetration testing skills
so there are two certifications over
here
one is the ecsa ec council certified
security analyst
once you clear that you get you can
appear for the license penetration
tester both of these are hands-on
certifications
so you will be given a virtual lab you
will
be given a scenario in which you'll have
to perform some assessments create
reports
submitted to the ec council they will
analyze your reports if they meet the
criterias that have been identified
you would then be certified as a
licensed penetration tester the
candidate must be above 18 years of age
a recertification is required every
three years so the validity is
three years after three years you will
have to be recertified or there is a
continuing point education
system over there where you can score
points by publishing articles by
attending trainings or giving out
trainings and you can get yourself
it is preferred that the candidate has
ceh and the ecsa certification
so the previous certification that we
saw certified ethical hacker
and then the ecsa ec council certified
security analyst
after which you can appear for the lpt
license penetration tester the
certificate provider again is ec council
the license penetration tester exam has
a different process the candidate must
purchase an exam dashboard for 899
which is valid for a year so once you
purchase the voucher the validity is one
year
you can prepare within that one year and
then give the exam and
attain the certification only once
you're ready the exam can be
scheduled and you can give that exam the
exam consists of three different levels
each level has three different
challenges the candidate must pass
at least one it is written by john
erickson
this book has two editions one which was
published in 2003
and the other in 2008. this book is
famous for the hacking approach
it teaches it focuses on network
security and computer security
it helps you understand how to develop
exploits rather than just using them
if you want to up your ethical hacking
game then this book definitely requires
a read
hacking the art of exploitation in its
second edition introduces you to c
programming from a hacker's perspective
out of the plethora of concepts that you
will learn in this book
few crucial ones are that you will learn
to program computers using c
and shell scripts you will also be able
to outplay security measures like
intrusion detection systems
having said that you will also learn to
hijack tcp connections crack
encrypted wireless traffic and speed up
brute force attacks
let's now have a look at the next
ethical hacking book on our list and
that is kali linux and ethical hackers
cookbook
this book revolving around kali linux is
written by himanshu sharma
kali linux is primarily used for
advanced penetration testing and also
for security auditing
it contains numerous tools that are
geared towards various security tasks
such as security research
penetration testing and so on this book
will help you get started with
installation and configuration of kali
linux which will enable you to perform
your tests
in addition to that you will learn to
perform web application exploitation
using tools such as burp you will also
be acquainted with performing network
exploitation using metasploit
and by a shark lastly you will know how
to conduct advanced penetration testing
these were few of the concepts you will
be learning besides a lot more others in
the book
at number 5 we have metasploit the
penetration testers guide
this book is written by four authors
david kennedy jimmy gorman
devon kearns and martiaroni the
metasploit framework is a powerful tool
for hackers to exploit ip addresses and
ports in it
this framework makes discovering and
exploiting vulnerabilities easy
but for first time users it can be a
little tricky hence this book will teach
you all about metasploit
you will learn the frameworks interfaces
module system
and more as you launch simulated attacks
after which you will move on to advanced
penetration testing techniques
which include network reconnaissance
client-side attacks
wireless attacks and targeted social
engineering attacks
you will also want to integrate nexpose
nmap and messes with metasploit to
automate discovery
up next we have penetration testing a
hands-on introduction to hacking
this book is written by georgia weedman
as the name suggests this book shows an
insight into penetration testing
a penetration tester discovers security
weaknesses in operating systems networks
and
applications penetration techniques are
used to gauge enterprise defenses
this book focuses on the core skills and
techniques a penetration tester requires
here you will go through the prime
stages of an actual assessment
which includes gathering information
untravel vulnerabilities gaining access
to networks and so on
in addition to the above you will learn
to crack passwords with the techniques
of brute forcing and word lists
bypass antivirus software automate
attacks and you will also learn to use
metasploit framework for launching
exploits and for writing your own
metasploit modules out of the many other
learnings
moving on to our next book we have the
hacker playbook 3.
the hacker playbook 3 practical guide to
penetration testing is written by peter
kim
this is the third iteration of the
hacker playbook series
it brings with itself new strategies
attacks exploits tips and tricks
besides all the new concepts it also
highlights a few techniques from the
previous versions
many schools have this book incorporated
in their teaching
the hacker playbook 3 red team edition
acquaints you with the red team
red teams simulate real world advanced
attacks to test your organization's
defensive teams
a red teamer will accurately test and
validate the overall security program
reading the hacker playbook 3 will help
you advance your offensive hacking
skills
and attack parts in addition to that it
also focuses on real-world attacks
exploitation
custom malware persistence and more
this heavily lab-based book will
incorporate several virtual machines
and custom the hacker playbook tools
at number eight we have black hat python
python programming for hackers and pen
testers
justin seeds is the author of this book
as you know python is a very strong
programming language and it comes to
great use when creating powerful and
effective hacking tools
python is the chosen language by many
security professionals across the world
and many exploit frameworks are written
in python
in this book you will go through the
darker side of python's capabilities
like infecting virtual machines
writing network sniffers creating
trojans etc
this book covers some networking
fundamentals interesting network tooling
web applications windows privilege
escalation tricks and
more this book as the author says is a
fun read
moving on at number nine we have the web
application hackers handbook finding and
exploiting security flaw
it is written by david started and
marcus pinto
this new edition focuses on updated web
applications
exposing them to attacks and executing
fraudulent transactions
this web application hackers handbook is
updated to speak about the latest
step-by-step methods for attacking and
defending the large range of ever
evolving web applications
it also discusses new remoting
frameworks html5
ui redress and hybrid file attacks to
name a few
it looks into attacking authentication
attacking the application server
finding vulnerabilities in source code
etc if you have already mastered the
first
edition you can focus on new concepts in
this one
now let's head to our last book on our
list at 10 we have web security testing
cookbook systematic techniques to find
problems first
the author of this book is parkour hope
and ben walther
security testing is quite often a
neglected one when it comes to the tests
performed on web applications
but it is a very crucial one this book
teaches you how to check for the most
common web security issues
it also acquaints you with installing
and configuring free and good security
testing tools
you will also understand how your
application communicates with users and
this book will help you build tests
pinpointed at ajax functions
and help you automate the tests with the
knowledge of this book and the free
tools used here you can defend your site
so those were the top 10 books for
ethical hacking
now that you had a look at the books
let's move on and see how simply learn
can help you become an ethical hacker
simply learn provides a certified
ethical hacker ch version 10
course this ca certification training
course provides you hands-on training
that will help you master the techniques
used to penetrate network systems and
defend your system against it
simply learn's ethical hacking course is
aligned with the latest ch version 10 by
ec council
here you will learn about trojans back
doors and counter measures
ids firewalls and honeypots advanced
hacking concepts network packet analysis
mobile and web technologies and advanced
log management
this course content includes an
introduction to ethical hacking
penetration testing
and ethical hacking concepts it also
speaks about sql injection
iot hacking and cryptography to name a
few there are no prerequisites to take
up this certification training course
ethical hacking is an integral part of
cyber security and it is gaining large
prominence today with the increase in
the number of cyber attacks
in this video we will run you through
the top 20 ethical hacking interview
questions
based on concepts like networking
software and programming
operating system and applications cyber
attacks and cryptography
so let's get started let's start off
with question one
what is a firewall now this is a very
good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall but
that's the functionality of a firewall
that is what how we can install a
firewall
but there are different types of
firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall is either a hardware
or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming
or outgoing traffic from the internet to
your computer they secure a network so
essentially
the firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen
it won't go beyond that that's the basic
functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done
based on the rules that you have created
on the firewall it will then
based on those rules identify whether
some traffic is allowed
in that network or some traffic is to be
blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows the firewall
rules will analyze whether the traffic
is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic
and not allow that connection from
happening in the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question
and the first one is a packet filtering
firewall these are the most common types
that you will come across
which analyze packets and lets them pass
through only if they match an
established
security rule set now here people do get
confused when we say that we analyze
packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct when a definition
for a packet filtering firewall says
that these firewalls analyze packets
it means that they are only analyzing
the source and destination ip addresses
port numbers and the protocols that are
mentioned in those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection
or dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you are basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next-gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets
for its source and destination ip
addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there
on the firewall and based on those rules
it will either allow that a collection
to happen or disallow that connection
from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level
they work at the layer 7 of the osi
model
packet filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they've worked on ip
addressing and port
numbers will work on the network layer
of the osi model
also on the transport layer because you
also look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the
application layer of the osi model and
will deal with application level
protocols such as http
https ftp smtp and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer app inspection firewall
these filter packets are the network
transport and application layers
so they basically do the job of the
first and the second type of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets
but now the first question is if there
is a stateful multi-layer inspection
firewall
why do we have type 1 and type 2
firewalls like packet filtering and
proxy firewalls that is because that is
how the firewalls have evolved
we started off with the packet filtering
then we added functionality to it
and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall
is to allow good traffic and disallow
bad traffic based on the rules that have
been configured on the firewall
and then you've got basically three
types of firewalls packet filtering
proxy
and stateful multi-layer and just
include a brief description
of each of these firewalls so that's
question one moving on to the question
two what is a vpn
vpn is also called a virtual private
network it is a connection between
a vpn server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
tunnel
between the client and the vpn server
which is then utilized
to secure the connections that you're
making with the
internet so as you can see in the
diagram the user has a vpn client
installed on the machine
the vpn client then creates an encrypted
tunnel to the vpn server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted
which can then be processed by the vpn
server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received backed by the
vpn server
the vpn server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the
communication mechanism they will not be
able to do so because of the encrypted
it is very difficult to decrypt this or
hack through this encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that
then question number three how do you
keep a computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so
you want to put your best foot forward
and you want to
identify the most common methodologies
on how you can keep a computer secure
so when you talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms
where you want multi-factor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure
that your accounts are kept secured now
if you look at
using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application
uh password attacks can be possible
either a brute force attack or a
dictionary based attack
uh or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks
you will need multi-factor
authentication to ensure that
accounts are kept secure now even if we
are
using multi-factor authentication we
also want to look at secure passwords
which means that the password is complex
enough to withstand most of the common
attacks
and a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible
so we want to randomize our passwords we
want to create a complexity where a
password meets
standards such as me has at least
one lowercase one uppercase character
has numerics
and special characters and is randomized
is not based on a dictionary word
doesn't contain usernames email
addresses phone numbers or anything that
is personal to that particular
user third keep regular updates
which means that there will be patches
that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing
download the patches install them on a
regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been identified
install a good antivirus could be an
internet security
suite which will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares
malwares and any script-based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system
could be a host-based firewall or a
network-based firewall to ensure that
attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions
in place to allow or disallow
connections from happening to your
devices
have anti-phishing software installed as
well to ensure that
you are not getting any spam mails even
if you do you're able to identify that
and not fall prey or victim to those
spam males phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they prey on the gullibility of that
particular individual
so our nigerian frauds or the lotteries
that we win on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars those
messages the emails that we receive
they are all phishing emails where
they're basically
prone to victimize the user and then
drop them off money or
install some malware or do some other
malicious activity
if you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices
or on your or that is accessed by your
software or being transmitted by your
software
use encryption encrypt your data whether
it is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
possibilities and finally in the
foremost secure your dns dns is the
domain name server
which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application
which may have a malware or a malicious
software
as a payload also you don't want
people to know your dns servers and the
queries that you're making
so you want to use secure dns or dns
over https
to encrypt your dns queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible
moving on to question number four what
are the different sources of malware
now malware stands for malicious
software right
malware is basically a software that
poses as a legitimate software but has a
payload of a trojan virus bioware
keylogger
or some malicious software that is going
to have a negative impact on security
of your particular device so the
question here is what are the different
sources of malware
we want to identify the most common
sources
through which malwares infect end-user
devices
and you can start with pop-up ads for
most of the websites if you are visiting
untrusted sites if you have been
redirected to sites that you don't know
about
there'll be a lot of pop-ups coming your
way when it says you're the 1 million
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift
or it will say uh congratulations on
winning a particular
product for visiting this page and so on
so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you
on top of the page and says that there
are eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack
to make gullible people click on those
links
now the software that is posing as a
security software itself
can be able to talk into the portal to
install it this is how your landing page
looks like
on your machine you see your compromise
branding up here on the top
left
which displays a human fascination with
usb so
if you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you're the one that you log
into what's on the us this is how you're
working you format it and you've got
your company name branding up here on
the higher the capacity
you see a microwave
so let's say you're surfing on the
internet you're looking for a software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website
you do not verify the trustworthiness of
that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source
to ensure that it is trustworthy and
only then are you going to download and
execute those files
thus internet downloads as well and when
we say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents
[Music]
[Music]
which may not be so much trustworthy and
we just download those files and start
installing them
that is a very bad scenario right so you
have to be very careful what you're
downloading from the internet
your anti-viruses your anti-fishing
uh mechanisms your threat intelligence
mechanisms
uh have those mechanisms installed
and you want to verify where your
downloads are coming from
then your network connections if it is a
p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify
whom which devices are or anything like
that
and if once they validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices
[Music]
if you're on a public wi-fi you probably
don't want to connect to a public
[Music]
then comes email attachments
there's so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a set format or a dart format
some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them
it shows us execution of this and then
finally there are these
facebook monitors whatsapp let it be um
any social media platform that you do or
even your
search engines their job is to display
ads
their job is not to verify whether the
ad is legit or not
it is for us as consumers to be careful
and validate that ad and verify whether
it is a genuine ad or not
so just don't start clicking on uh any
of the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be
sure that you are investigating that so
these are the most
common sources of malware and
the end user will always get infected by
one of these mechanisms
then moving on to question number five
how does email work
now this is a very uh can be a complex
question
uh but we have to keep it as simple as
possible and we have to identify that
there are
uh two servers while both of them
either using smtp which is the simple
message transfer protocol
where in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine
which is connected to the mail exchange
server which has a dns server which
maps the routing and which maps the
exchange server and inboxes so when john
composes that message and clicks on send
john should be connected to a mail
exchange server
where the email is sent through that
particular person's inbox
so john's inbox will then uh
be validated and that email will then be
sent through the dns server
uh through the internet and will be
received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time john also requires
the recipient's email address so in this
case this is jack
so jack at something.com would be the
email address
so while john is composing uh the two
field will have jack's email address
the from field will have john's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself
and then when john clicks on send it
will go to
direction server the exchange server
will then validate the
inbox and identify where that inbox is
located
for jack and then to the internet it
will be sent
to the uh to the mail server of jack the
mail server will then identify the
proper
inbox that it now that that email is to
be sent to and it will store that email
in that particular inbox
when jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox
this email from john will be already
waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
john had sent that email
moving on to question number six what is
black box and white box testing so when
you're testing a software
or you're testing your infrastructure
there are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one
is a white box in a black box test there
is no knowledge that is shared with the
tester so
let's say you're an ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization
to test the current application that
they have developed
now they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an ip address and a
port number where the application is
hosted
and now you have to fire in your own
queries and try to figure out
what the application is try to gather
information
see what uh what information can be
gathered in the first place and based on
that
you're going to figure out your way
identify vulnerabilities
and see if any of those vulnerabilities
can lead to an security incident
so without any knowledge zero knowledge
of the id infrastructure or the source
code
that's a black box attack or a black box
test
a white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the id
infrastructure of the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify
right so why would these two audits be
important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates
the attack of a outsider a external
hacker sitting
outside the organization trying to
figure their way in whereas a white box
attack
can emulate the attack of an insider so
a disgruntled employee within that
organization
misusing their access controls or the
access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits
right so somebody's corrupt who has been
bribed
who wants to sell out company secrets
based uh so they're going to try to find
out vulnerabilities
try to steal data and try to sell it on
the uh
gray market right so a white box would
emulate a internal attack
a black box would emulate an external
attack
the next question is what are the steps
involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of an ethical
hacking question
you're looking at devices and for and
the interviewer asks you
uh what kind of steps are involved what
are the activities that you would do
in hacking a server or a network now
there are no specific steps that you
would
define because every hack is going to be
unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always
always be the recognizance step also
known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the
information that is possible about the
targets that they want to attack
so here you're trying to get to know the
victims so you can launch specific
attacks
towards them you want to identify what
operating system they are utilizing what
ip addresses mac addresses
the versions of the operating systems
and applications the patch levels
find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible
find out the information about the
person who's using those computers
so you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so
the first step is all about gathering
enough information
based on which you can launch further
attacks once you have that information
comes the second phase which is known as
the scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so you
have in the first step you've got your
ip addresses domain names
maybe even network maps and you have
identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live devices and then you're going to
scan them for open ports processes
protocols services you're going to
identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities
or a certain set of security loopholes
that you can misuse once you have
identified those
you are going to the next step which is
the gaining access state
in this you are actually going to
execute your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found
and you are either going to gain access
to that particular system by installing
a trojan
or destroy the system by installing a
virus or install a spyware or a
keylogger
whatever you wanted to achieve so in the
gaining
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you gain in the first and
the second phase you're going to launch
your attacks and you're going to try to
gain access
to that particular device then the next
step is where you're going to maintain
that access now that you have hacked
into that device it is not necessary
that you will always be able to get
access to that device
uh suppose you have cracked the password
of that particular user and the user
changes that password
after a few days your attack is
worthless so what you're going to do
here is you're going to maintain your
access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you're going to install a keylogger
or a trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device
without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks
so whatever activity that we have done
so far will
have created logs and will have created
information
based on which the victim will come to
know that they have been compromised and
may be able to trace that activity back
to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked
and to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity
you are going to hide the files that you
have created so you have installed a
trojan or a keylogger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered
you're going to hide processes that have
been created you're going to try to
hide all the activity that you have done
so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have been
compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application or
any computing device you'll come across
the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network-based attack
where you're trying to capture
uh data packages that that are being
transmitted over the network and then
you're going to analyze them
to see if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
bank details or anything of that sort
now
these tools will also depend on which
operating system you're utilizing
for example msn sniffer would work on
microsoft
operating systems cab would be
based on linux and so on so forth so on
the screen you'll see six different
sniffing tools that work on different
operating systems
wireshark is uh something that is common
both on windows and linux
it is used to analyze network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across
in most of your ethical hacking
trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do data captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and
network administrators to analyze any
issues that may be going on in the
network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark
like we stated is available for windows
linux
uh as well then there is tcp dump
which uh again has the same capability
of wireshark
but is a command line version whereas
wireshark also has a gui
a graphical user interface tcp dump is
available
on linux msn sniffer it's
a very old tool uh when we had msn
messengers
uh msn messenger is no longer there but
microsoft does or did have a microsoft
message analyzer tool
uh which they have stopped development
since 2015
but that's another tool that is specific
for microsoft operating systems from
microsoft
that can be installed together more
information then you've got eater cap
which is a tool to launch man in the
middle attacks
data capturing and is essentially a
linux command line based
tool then d sniff is another password
and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data package
prominently a linux tool
same with eatery this is a graphical
tool which will allow you to capture
data
data traffics and map protocols and
identify which ip addresses have been
communicating with what
essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like
launching manual attacks or capturing
or having specific filters that will
help you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
question nine what is sql injection sql
stands for
structured query language which is a
language that is used by most of your
databases
or your relational databases
the variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql
oracle sql you'll have ibm databases all
of these databases utilize the
structured query languages
to interact with the applications now
all of these
databases have their own syntax so
you'll have to study
most of these databases based on which
applications and which databases you
want to provide security for
but as the name suggests sql injection
vulnerability or
structured query language injection
vulnerability is where a user can
maliciously inject
a sql input or a sql statement
in a query and send it to the database
and evoke a response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database
it uh the vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application
so when the application receives a query
which it needs to be forwarded to the
sql
database we need to configure and the
application level
of what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various
aspects of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability
but the basic flaw lies in the
application where
invalidated input is accepted and sent
forward
to the database where the database might
confuse it
into an executable statement and thus
create
a response that was not warranted
there are various types of sql
injections as shown on the screen
in-band sequence injection where you can
look at an error-based or a union based
injection
a blind sql injection where it is either
boolean based or
a time-based attack and then an
out-of-bound sql
injection essentially you're looking at
databases and you're looking at
application security
where you want to encourage secure
coding practices so
in unvalidated input is mitigated the
next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing you're basically
assuming the identity of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an email
that appears to be a legitimate email it
looks almost
genuine it has been constructed to
replicate
what a genuine email would have been and
it is very difficult to spot
a fake one there are different ways to
identify whether
email is genuine or not if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
moving on to the next question what is a
distributed denial of service attack
or a ddos attack now generally a denial
of service attack is
an attack where legitimate users are
prevented access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for example if it is a bandwidth-based
attack
the attacker consumes the bandwidth of
the network in such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users
to access the network now a single
device may not be able to generate that
much amount of
traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server
thus the attacker will construct a bot
net
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim right so a botnet
uh
there are two terms that you want to
look at over here the first
term is a bot and the second one being
the botnet itself
bot is a software that once installed on
a victim's machine
allows the hacker to send remote
commands to that machine
that will make it to generate some
activity
once we have enough machines on which
such bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botnet
so an attacker would then instruct this
entire botnet
to start generating data traffic to be
to be sent to the targeted network or to
the targeted server
which will then pop down the server
that's crashing it and preventing
users from accessing that particular
resource the next question is how to
avoid
our poisoning or arp now
first let's understand what arp is arp
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network
once your computer boots up it starts a
discovery process
of identifying its neighbors so if i'm
in a particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out a
rp request an address resolution
protocol
to find out which other machines are
within the same network
and which are live once it sends out a
query a live machine will respond to
that query along
with its mac address
this information is then stored in what
is known as a arp
table or an arb table on the machine's
cache so whenever my machine now wants
to send out a packet to this particular
machine
it will go to the arp table it will
identify the ip address
and the associated mac address it will
print that onto the data packet
as a destination uh ip and destination
mac
and send that packet across the switch
the switch will then identify the mac
address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is
connected to that particular switch now
to confuse the switch
into sending it to a different machine
our poisoning attack is
created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the middle
attack
now to prevent this arm poisoning from
happening in the first place
there are three different aspects that
we can utilize
first we can use packet filtering which
will
filter out and block packets that are
the same source address data so you have
identified some malicious ip addresses
and you want to block out some ip
addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall
where you have constructed the firewall
to filter out certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses
this firewall and this technique will
then block those kind of packets coming
in
second keeping away from trust
relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships
and thus you want to keep this protocol
away from that
once you have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be
sending out arp requests to other
machines in the first place since
uh that translation has been defined and
these machines know whom to communicate
with
such kind of protocols should then be
disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some
there are software's out there that will
look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software and
it will be mitigated of network
visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force
uh they haven't built capabilities of
identifying uh
our uh spoofing attacks and mitigate
them in the first place
in the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware now
ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories
let's just revisit what ransomware is
let's start with the word malware
malware is a malicious software
that poses as a legitimate software but
has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine
so in this instance viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware
a trojan is a software that will give
you back door access to it
to a particular device a virus will do
some destructive activity on that device
a ransomware will basically encrypt the
data
of that particular user from on that
particular machine
thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand a ransom to
provide access
to that particular data so the three
types of ransomwares
the first one is scareware which uses
social engineering to cause
anxiety or the perception of a threat to
manipulate users into buying unwanted
software
so this preys on the gullibility of
humans where
you can see a pop-up appearing on your
screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked
or there is a virus on your machine and
then instructs you to download a
particular software
to mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading
and then a ransomware will be installed
and your data will be encrypted
screen lockers uh where locking uses
computers by preventing them
from logging in and displaying an
official looking message
you will see a screen saver once you
boot up which prevents you from
accessing the login page so it will not
allow you to log into your own machine
but it will give you a warning that your
data has been encrypted and you need to
connect to
a particular email address and send it
to send bitcoins over there
to get a decryption key to access your
own data
and then the encrypting so ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file
so once your files have been encrypted
you might just have a blank screen in
front of you
where you'll receive a warning message
uh where it instructs you to pay up
a ransom in bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency
to some particular digital e-wallet
which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data
then talking about the next question
what is the difference between an active
and a passive cyber attack
now when we talk about cyber attacks
cyber attack is an
activity that is caused by a malicious
user who wants to try to
get access or do some security incidents
on the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen
it's either in an active manner or a
passive manner in an active manner the
intruder attempts
to disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data
and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active
where the attacker will proactively try
to
destroy the network so that
communications fail
or they might try to modify the data
where uh
we're using a ransom where they can
encrypt it or they might delete that
data using a virus
or steal that data using a trojan or
they might even
alter the data uh so that it is no
longer
trustworthy whereas in a passive attack
the intruder intercepts data traveling
through a network here the intruder
eavesdrop but does not modify the
message so they're just listening in
they're just observing what is going on
they are not manipulating the data they
are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring what
the activity that's going on
the next question what is a social
engineering attack
now social engineering attack is a
people based attack the victim here
is the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human
it may be executed through a computer
but
end of the day the gullibility is of the
human so it is the art
of manipulating people so that they end
up giving up
confidential information now we always
read in the papers where somebody got
manipulated their passwords got hacked
and somebody's life savings got wiped
out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people
will fall prey to this attack and share
this kind of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information
now there are three categories in this
attack one the first one is a phishing
attack
second is a sphere phishing attack and a
third is a railing attack
now phishing attack is basically a
generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that
attack will be a victim whereas a spear
phishing attack
is a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into
spearfishing
where you analyze the victim you try to
figure out what the vulnerabilities are
and you tailor make or you customize the
attack
to that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people
those people will then fall prey to this
attack
an availing attack is where you're
attacking
top level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
uh so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a
veiling attack next question what is man
in the middle attack now this is
something that we had touched based when
we talked about
arp where the arp poisoning attack needs
to be
executed to leverage a man in the middle
attack
now in the man in the middle attack the
attacker
attacking computer takes the ip address
of the client unaware of this the
server continues to communicate with the
attacker now if you remember
in a previous question we have also
talked about spoofing so in this
scenario
uh attacker has spoofed their ip address
to replicate themselves as a
genuine client and now with that
spoofing in mind they might either
through
our poisoning attack or just because of
the spoofed ip address
become a man in the middle that means
that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves
as a server in this scenario the
attacker
is now a go between between the client
and the server
and can eavesdrop and can copy the data
if they want they can modify the data as
well so as
you can see on the screen the attacker
becomes man in the middle
which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client
and the server the next question who are
black hat hackers and white head hackers
the main thing is the differentiation
between a black hat hacker and a white
hat hacker
now our black hat hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain
these individuals are known also known
as security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent those
who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain or for the matter of
disruption
the main thing that black hat hackers
lack
is authorization they are not authorized
to do the activity that they are about
to do
and they are going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data
which is going to cause losses to the
organization involved
whereas on the other side a white hat
hacker are also known as ethical hackers
these are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities
they help the organizations defend
themselves from black hat hackers
so the main difference between these two
types of hackers a black hat and a white
hat
is the intent and the authorization
so black hat hackers will have malicious
intent they will try to
personally gain from that attack from by
finding out vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the whitehead
hacker can do
to find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the white hat hacker
they will report it to the management
and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities
the main difference between a black hat
and a white hat is the authorization
and the intent the next question what
are honey
now honeypots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh
these basically are decoy servers that
are implemented in a network to
attract the attention of our attacker it
is there to lure an attacker
into attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall
and is now trying to scan a particular
network when they scan they will come
across
various devices that are there in the
network they will then proceed to do a
vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time
will provide as an approve as an
attraction to these attackers because it
will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker
which will divert their attention so
these vulnerabilities are simulated on
these devices these actually do not
exist
but the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honeypot the
honeypot will identify that as a
malicious traffic
and will warm the one the administrator
about a possible attack that is going on
the administrator will then investigate
through the honeypot of what activity is
going on
and then reconfigure the security
controls to block the attacker or
mitigate the attack itself
right so it is more of a decoy server
that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities to an attacker
thus to lure them and safeguard the rest
of the network moving on to the next
question
define cryptography encryption and
decryption
now cryptography is used by security
professionals to scramble data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format
and then reversing it back to readable
format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking
like an unreadable format now if you
look at this word that it has been
scrambled into
it would be very difficult for a human
to figure out what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where
we have made a shift of the alphabet
where we have added two alphabets the
current one so c
plus 2 becomes e o plus 2
becomes q m plus 2 becomes o so we have
done a shift
of 2 and thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus two so
any person who
figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key
is what cryptography is all about now
as we discussed the decryption again is
uh replacing the alphabet
and taking it further back by two
characters
so e minus two becomes c q minus 2
becomes o
o minus 2 becomes m and so on so forth
so anybody who knows this key
the shift key anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus five
then the spacing the shifting of that
character will be
the fifth character from that particular
character and so on so forth
and now the last question what is the
difference between cipher text and clear
text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible
so the word computer is clear text that
means that it has not been treated to
any cryptographic measures
it does what it is intended to be
however
if the moment we encrypt it that means
we scramble it into unreadable text
by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text and
without the key
this becomes unreadable the clear text
as discussed is the plain word that we
have utilized we are using the english
language in this instance
so the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on ethical hacker full course
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
you